. Hallo Berlin! Hallo, schön, dass Sie da sind, Berlin. Danke, es ist wirklich anstrengend, es war anstrengender als ich dachte. Wenn du nicht verbeugst, dann klatschen die weiter, wir haben mehr Zeit, um auszurücken. Dankeschön, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank, Stefan Tietze, meine Damen und Herren. Flotin, meine Damen und Herren. Und ihr seid Bernd und Sophie und Susanne, schön, dass ihr da seid. Hey, da ist ein Platz leer geblieben, in der ersten Reihe. Das ist kein gutes Zeichen, wenn man das die ganze Zeit jetzt sieht, dass sich Leute gegen uns entschieden haben. Ich muss aber tatsächlich ganz ehrlich sagen, auf dem Weg hierher, wir sind in so einer gefährlichen Schlangengrubengegend, um uns herum sind so viele interessante Dinge. Ich dachte, niemand schafft es auf dem Weg zu her. Du kommst hierher, links von dir erstmal Hasenheide Drogen, die ersten, die da noch mal schon nicht abbiegen, gehen weiter, dann Bowling, wo erst mal für's sagen, fuck it, Podcast-Hufo oder Bowling, ich sag mal so, das wird ein Home Run. Wenn ich nach Köln nach Hause fahre, ist links das Phantasialand, diese Abfahrt, Und ich denke mir jedes Mal so, ja, alleine masturbieren oder Zuckerwatte? Ja, und dann bin ich hier als erster von uns angekommen heute und ich stand halt vor dem Eingang der Spielothek. Und dann kam ein Typ und hat gesagt, ah, du willst hier rein? Ja, ich bin einer der Künstler, die heute auf der Bühne stehen. Und er hat mich so ein bisschen angeguckt und gesagt, ja, hm, bist du das wirklich? Du bist wirklich Candy88, der heute Abend auftritt. Und ich habe gesagt, ja, ja, das bin ich, und dann hat er mich in so einen Raum, also in so eine Treppe, so eine Stahltreppe hochgeführt, und dann stand da drüber auch Spielothek. Und ich dachte mir, gut, das ist mein Tod, das ist jetzt einfach, das ist der perfekte Mord. Ich wäre einfach mit ihm straight mitgegangen, er hätte jetzt ein anderes Leben geführt, aber er hat mich dann bisher nicht hierher gebracht. Ich denke mir oft, ich wäre so leicht umzubringen, also falls Mörder da draußen sind, Leute meldet euch wirklich. Vor allem, ich finde Vans nicht gefährlich, Vans sind praktisch. Und wenn da keine Fenster drin sind, dann blendet dich nichts beim Fahren. So nämlich, viel Stauraum, hinten das ganze Gaffer-Tape, Gaffer-Tape ist wahnsinnig süsslich. Ich schaue gerne diese True-Crime-Serien auf Netflix, wo dann immer so, oh, dann wurde die umgebracht. Woo, Netflix. Woo, Verbrechen, sehr gut. Obwohl Amazon Prime auch sehr gut ist, muss ich gar nicht sagen. Man weiss nicht, ob es auch gut war jetzt, ob er für das True oder für das Crime gejubelt hat. Man weiss es nicht genau. Für die Wahrheit, viele Wahrheit-Fans heute hier, woo, true. Und ich denke immer so, und dann weiss man ja, dass die am Ende stirbt, meistens sind Frauen, und dann immer so, ja, und dann hat er sie gefragt, ob sie vorbeikommen will im Wald, und ich denke ich denke immer so, will ich auch gemacht, will ich auch vorbeikommen? Ich habe da so ein Baumhaus neun Meilen von hier entfernt, Baumhaus geil, ist doch gut, kann man hoch. Ja, wie Serial, der Podcast, wo die einfach die ganze Zeit von einem Leben berichten, von diesem College-Kid, und der hat einfach das coolste Leben, so ein sehr relatable Leben, und dann einfach mit einem Mord da drin, halt so casual. Und man denkt, ja, es hätte auch dein Leben sein können. Und damit herzlich willkommen zu Comedy Show heute Abend. Ihr hättet auch tot sein können. Das ist der Titel unserer nächsten Tour, Tour Nummer drei. Vielleicht wärt ihr tot. Den nächsten Tourtitel haben wir schon festgesetzt, der ist, kann ein langer Abend werden, dann kann kommen, ihr hättet auch tot sein können. Das stimmt. Glaubst du, es ist schon mal vollkommen, dass jemand sich eine Ticket gekauft hat und dann gestorben ist, kurz bevor es ... Ja, okay. Sorry, grosses Beileid, grosses Beileid. Mal zehn Schweigeminuten für den Herrn in der ersten Reihe. Das wäre sehr gut, weil da muss man sich keine Witze ausdenken. Das stimmt, ja. Ich habe, glaube ich, noch nie eine Schweigeminute damit verbracht, was man während einer Schweigeminute machen soll. Ja, genau, die Zeit nutze ich damit, mich über Leute aufzureden, die die Schweigeminuten nicht nutzen, die dann einfach die ganze Zeit reden. Und ich zähle auch immer mit, also ich weiß nicht, da war dann keine Ahnung in der Schweizer Schulzeit. Es ist nie eine Minute. Es ist nie eine Minute und es gibt Lehrer, die machen zu lang und es gibt Lehrer, die machen zu kurz. Sehr spezielle Richtung jetzt. Aber bei uns in der Schule, da war irgendwie alle zwei Wochen Amoklauf und dann ständig, also nicht an unserer Schule. Ständig Amoklauf, ne? Und dann ständig irgendwie die Schweigeminute und man war irgendwie schon so drin, das gehörte dazu. Och, schon wieder ein Amoklauf. Und du denkst dir nur, bitte während Latein, bitte Schweigeminute während Latein, nur nicht während Sport, denn ich liebe Sport. Sport ist dein Leben, wie man sieht, du hast eine Jogginghose an. Es ist übrigens, man muss sagen, es ist die Original-Podcast-UFO, also man hat uns einen Trainingsanzug geschenkt. Man hat irgendwie so eine Booking-Agentur, die dann anfängt, die Locations auszusuchen und so weiter. Und die haben uns zum Start der Tour einen Jogginganzug geschenkt. Was ist das für ein Zeichen zuerst? Schwierig, ich würde sagen. Genau, und dann ist die Hose, aber dann haben sie uns halt hinten drauf, ist auf der Trainingsherde so ein großes Podcast-Ufo-Logo, was cool ist. Aber auf der Hose ist nichts vom Podcast-Ufo. Das heißt, die haben uns im Prinzip, du trägst Podcast-Ufo-Merch, aber sie ist einfach eine Adidas-Hose. Ich glaube, man merkt es ein bisschen. Das sieht ein bisschen so aus. Ich schaue ja gerade wahnsinnig viel Sopranos wieder, ja, ich weiß, und die tragen auch alle Trainingsanzüge. Und als dieser anonyme Trainingsanzug bei uns im Backstage lag, dachte ich, fang man jetzt in der Mafia? Wie kommt man in eine Mafia immer so? Manche werden reingeboren, andere nicht. Ja, wie stand das für den Prozess? Wo fängst du an? Ja, und ich glaube, das ist eine Art Bewerbungsverfahren, du brauchst einen Podcast erst mal und dann hören die Mafiosi so, ja, der hat was drauf, ist ein krasser Typ, weil in der Mafia wird man ja auch ständig abgehört, da trägt man ja auch immer diese Kabel vom FBI und so, deswegen ist glaube ich so ein Podcast ganz gut, weil das bereitet dich auf die Arbeit vor. Und wenn die sagen, okay, der ist gut drauf, dann schenkt man dem so einen Trainingsanzug. Fühlt sich nicht so schlecht. Vielleicht bin ich jetzt in der Mafia. Man kriegt das glaube ich gar nicht mit. Ich weiß es gar nicht. Ich glaube, ich wäre so schlecht in der Mafia. Aber lass das vielleicht nicht vor so vielen Leuten besprechen, ob wir in der Mafia sind oder nicht. Ich würde auch eher dich in der Mafia erwarten, eigentlich so. Weil die brauchen ja auch immer einen in der Mafia, auf den sie dann alles schieben können. Wenn dann mal irgendwann kommt und dann so... Nee, Stefan war es. Okay, Stefan ist verhaftet. Und du dann so zu... Ich bin der Erste, der verhaftet worden wird, das stimmt schon, ja. Wir haben, muss man mal sagen, nächste Woche startet, oder in zwei Wochen startet unsere Schülerpraktikantin, wir haben nämlich, es wurde sich bei uns beworben, jemand hat sich für ein Schülerpraktikum bei einem Podcast beworben und wir dachten, wo endet diese Anfrage, die endet mit uns, wie wir im Knast sitzen, wahrscheinlich. Ja, einer von uns beiden, wir beide und eine 15-Jährige, einer von uns beiden geht in den Knast. Einer von uns beiden geht im Knast. Das ist die Geschichte, das ist der Titel der nächsten Tour. Ich sitze dann hier mit so einem Telefon und du dann mit so einem großen Monitor, mit du und per Skype zugeschaltet und dann mit so einem orangenen Anzug die ganze Zeit. Gefängnis Köln, dieser Anruf wird überwacht von beiden Seiten. Hi, hi. Ja, das finde ich gut. Ne, genau, und da bin ich sehr gespannt, wie das läuft. Und da glaube ich, landen wir im Knast, das ist sehr, sehr wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaube auch. Jedenfalls haben wir sie, und sie wird ein paar Aufgaben für uns übernehmen, also könnt ihr euch darauf freuen.
Wir schicken sie mit dem Mikrofon auf jeden Fall los und dann wollen wir mal gucken, wie strafrechtlich relevant das ist.
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, man weiß ja nicht so, ich glaube so bei der Schülerpraktikum ist ja auch scheißegal,
ich weiß nicht, ob Julia, gute Kollegin von uns, ich weiß nicht, ob das etwas ist, was sie in dem Buch beschreibt, aber die wollte ja mal ein Praktikum machen bei so einem Hähnchenverkäufer. Und dann hat die Lehrer gesagt, das ist nicht akademisch genug, das ist nicht krass genug. Moment, Hähnchen stand, aber Podcast-Sufu ist okay, oder was? Ich weiß es nicht. Jedenfalls dachten wir, wir sagen mal zu, zu, weil erstmal ist es einfacher immer ja zu sagen, es ist schwierig nein zu sagen und es wird doch eh nicht passieren, weil da gibt es ja Lehrer, die darauf achten, wo sie das macht, das Praktikum, fun fact, nein, ist dem scheißegal, der Lehrer hat das zugesagt und es ist sie bei uns und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wisst, aber wir nehmen einmal die Woche, wenn es hochkommt, auf, es ist nicht so, sie hat nicht so viel zu tun, sie geben ihr was zu tun. Falls euch wundert, dass die Folgen vielleicht ein bisschen merkwürdig geschnitten sind und Stefan wahnsinnig laut ist. Stefan ist wahnsinnig laut, das sag ich vorher. Dann wirklich ein, ah okay, da hat mal jemand anders. Passend, ich will kurz vor das Rufung. Aber stimmt, es wird grossartig, ich bin sehr gespannt. Das ist eine geschichtsträchtige Halle. Ja, das stimmt, Stefan hat ein bisschen recherchiert. Man muss sagen, die NS-Zeit ist ja auch nicht ohne Spuren zu hinterlassen durchgezogen, muss man sagen. Goebbels war hier häufig. Großer Applaus. Letztens waren wir in der Backstage, wo Poster hinten hängen von Ingo Appelt und so, und wir dachten, hier hat Ingo Appelt schon mal gesessen. Wir sassen auf dem gleichen Sofa wie Ingo Appelt.
Und heute ist Goebbels.
So, daran weiss man, weisst du, was hier uraufgeführt wurde in Berlin eigentlich?
Du hast jetzt immer ein Funfact, was wurde uraufgeführt?
Zweiter Weltkrieg wurde in Berlin uraufgeführt, ein bisschen.
Die Lesetour von Hitler, Mein Kampf.
Bei der ersten Lesung war er noch sehr nervös, muss man sagen, mit so einem Künstlerschal und so ein Glas Rotwein.
Also ich lese heute aus meinem Buch vor, ist noch nicht ganz fertig und so, es gibt noch ein paar Details und ich lese einfach mal vor.
Ich glaube, es lief nicht gut.
Nee, es gab viele Fragen danach, glaube ich.
Vor allem so viele Bilder, irgendwie, jede zweite Seite ist ein Bild und ja, ich halte es mal hoch, kurz, ich kann es mal kurz rumgehen und dann, oh scheiße, jetzt ist es weg.
Es ist einfach, wenn du dich nicht befasst mit sowas, eine Lesung ist auch nicht leicht. Ja,, ich glaube, der Satz, ich lasse das mal rumgehen, ist sehr schwierig bei der Lesung, ja. Nee, auch bis dahinten, bitte. Und dann, aber hast du mitbekommen, dass, ja, sorry, wollte ich nicht unterbrechen. Nee, ich wollte auch gerade sagen, dass ich noch nie was richtig habe rumgehen lassen. Ich hatte immer, weil man, das ist der Moment in dem Referat, wo jemand sagt, ich lasse das mal rumgehen. Oh, ich liebe es, das was du tun als Publikum. Nee, und, vor allem ich achte da nur noch drauf, wo ist es gerade, wo ist es gerade. Wann komme ich, kommt es von links, kommt es von rechts. Gerade Reihe, ungerade Reihe und währenddessen irgendwie Zitzaro oder so. Oh, das stimmt, ich war in Wien in einem Theater, einem Burgtheater und da ging es so ein Stück und da hat der, es ging um Stand-up-Comedien und das ganze Programm war im Prinzip ein Stand-up-Programm. Also du warst bei dem Stand-Up-Programm. Ohne es zu wollen. Ich wollte zum Burgtheater.
Bitte setzen Sie sich hier in den Stand-Up.
Und dann hat er irgendwann eine
Wodka-Flasche rumgehen lassen.
Und ich dachte mir,
wie cool, ich will wissen, ist da Wasser drin,
ist da Wodka drin, weil das die, wo er auch vorher lange
daraus getrunken hat und so. Vielleicht ist er einfach ein sehr guter
Schauspieler und er hat nicht wirklich daraus getrunken, aber ich dachte mir,
wie cool, wenn es so wirklich Wodka ist. Und er hat die rumgehen
lassen und genau in meiner Reihe ist sie nicht lange gegangen. Das ist wirklich schlimm. Du saßt in der Kinderreihe oder so, also kein Alkohol. Das ist aber echt abgefahren, aber es ist tatsächlich bei uns, wir hatten auch so mal, während ich mal die 40 Minuten, die ich studiert habe in meinem Leben, da gab es auch so ein Seminar und so viele, so viele Seminare sind immer so ein bisschen alternativ und so super krass und dann so total freiheitlich und dann der Dozent sagt so, ja, ich schreibe euch jetzt mal die Zahl auf, wie viel ich für dieses Seminar hier bekomme von der Uni. Und dann schreibt er so eine Zahl auf, 600 Euro oder irgendwie, nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Und dann sagt er so, was machen wir mit dem Geld? So, und dann wird irgendwie... Die Reaktionen aus dem Publikum sagen, entweder es ist doch sehr viel oder es ist sehr, sehr wenig oder ich schlache aber alles, weil ich schon drei Bier drin habe. aber ich weiß nicht. Die Kultusministerin jauchzt auf in der ersten Reihe, was? Und dann durften wir als Kurs entscheiden, was der Dozent mit dem Geld macht und dann haben sie natürlich so, wir zünden die BWL-Fakultät an, wir sind total krass und irgendwie total die Philosophie. Man weiss schon, warum es Philosophie-Studenten sind. Ja, ja, und am Ende hat er irgendwie eine Flasche Rotwein gekauft und hat die rumgehen lassen. Ich weiss auch nicht, inwiefern das jetzt dem Spirit gleich kam, aber da habe ich auch nichts von bekommen. Das erinnert mich an diesen Twitter-Thread, den ich gelesen habe. Oh, Thread, das klingt wirklich wahnsinnig toll. Und da hat eine Lehrerin so ein Experiment versucht, nämlich von Black Mirror, und gesagt, Leute, die gut bewertet werden, angenommen in einer Gesellschaft, wo alle sich immer bewerten, sind die Leute, die sehr gut bewertet werden, werden bevorzugt behandelt, die kriegen die Wohnung, die kriegen die Freunde ab und günstiger Sachen usw. Und dann hat sie in der Klasse dieses System etabliert und hat gesagt, wenn ihr freundlich euch meldet und wenn ihr euch am Unterricht beteiligt und wenn ihr ruhig seid, dann kriegt ihr gute Bewertung und dann dürft ihr vorne sitzen usw. Und sie hat das halt so ein bisschen... Das ist eine Lehrerin, die hat wirklich verstanden, was Schüler wollen. Genau, Leute wollen vorne sitzen. Dann dürft ihr fünf Minuten früher kommen. Dann dürft ihr lernen, dann dürft ihr jetzt schon mal effigenia auf Taures lesen, habt ihr Bock? Und tatsächlich hat das sehr gut funktioniert. Und ein so ein Typ hat sich halt nicht beteiligt und der wurde gnadenlos ausgeschlossen aus der Klasse. Der wurde dann von der Klasse nach draußen verwiesen und das ging irgendwie 15 Minuten und dann hat sich direkt so ein diewelleartiges System etabliert und Nico wurde nach draußen auf den Gang gesetzt und wurde getreten von Leuten. Hies er wirklich Nico? Doch, es wird in den Threads sogar erwähnt. Okay. Ja, und das wäre sehr interessant. Und dann plötzlich das System einfach gekippt und man merkt so, ja klar, wir sind mittlerweile in einem sehr beliebtheitsorientierten, sagen wir, Beliebtheitswettbewerb, das ist doch die Gesellschaft, in der wir leben. So, um mal ein bisschen Propaganda hier in diesen heiligen Hallen zu verbreiten. Ja, wofür genau? Weiß ich noch nicht genau, Black Mirror im Kern, im Kern von Netflix. Aber die Halle bietet sich einfach an für Propaganda, du hast einfach Bock in Polen einzufallen, wenn du einfach mal hier bist. Ja, oder nicht Leute. Komm jetzt lass uns einfach machen, scheiss drauf. Ja, vielleicht nicht Polen, vielleicht nicht Spanien, wo es warm ist, genau. Ja, genau, ja, das stimmt schon. Tatsächlich, ich habe mal mit Kindern gearbeitet während meiner Zivildienstzeit und da gab es auch so ein Bewertungssystem, so grüner Punkt für Sachen gut gemacht, roter Punkt für Sachen schlecht gemacht. Und ich dachte mir, wow, was für ein interessantes pädagogisches System, aha, okay, was gibt's da für Leitlinien, wie kann man das... So hast du gesprochen damals. Das war nach meinem Einschluck Rotwein, da war ich dann die ganze Zeit. Und tatsächlich war es so, dass diese Punkte letztlich einfach Geld waren. Das heißt, am Ende der Woche haben die Kinder für jeden, wurde ausgerechnet, die roten Punkte wurden für den grünen abgezogen, und was übrig bleibt, kriegt man 10 Cent für jeden grünen Punkt. Und dann ist man alles zum Norma gegangen und dann dürfen die Leute sich Sachen kaufen, also die Kinder, die Leute. Und das heißt, im Endeffekt haben die gelernt, wenn ich gut bin, kriege ich Geld. Einfach die ganze Belohnungsschleppur. Aber ist nicht das, wie die Gesellschaft funktioniert? Geld. Ja, gut, das ist natürlich deine beissende Satire. Du machst mich fertig heute. Keine Ahnung. Ihr geht heute alle klüger aus dieser Halle und ein bisschen rassistischer vielleicht als das Vorhaben.
Apropos Rassismus, hast du mitbekommen die Geschichte, dass der Erfinder, der Entdecker der DNA, dem wurde jetzt der Nobelpreis aberkannt, weil er ein fucking Rassist ist? Wirklich? Der Entdecker der DNA vertritt Thesen wie, ja, Schwarze sind einfach nicht so clever. Und man denkt so, bitte, what the fuck, das kann doch nicht dann scheiß ernst sein. Aber das ist wirklich so. Der hat das damals entdeckt alles und alle ist ein bisschen, es ist so, darf man jetzt noch DNA mögen? Darf man sich jetzt noch reproduzieren, ist die Frage. Oder ist das jetzt auch schon? Ist Wissenschaft nicht fragwürdig jetzt so ein bisschen. Das ist auch schon kontrovert. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es auch ein bisschen lustig, weil dieser Gegensatz da drin ist, aber es ist auch echt hart. Aber vielleicht hat er sich nur mit DNA beschäftigt, weil er irgendwie das Rassistengehen finden wollte, wo er halt sagen würde, ja, was macht Schwarze so dumm? Und dann hat er halt geguckt, finde ich das Gehen? Ja, wo man auch mal sagen muss, Rassismus ist ein scheiss geiler Antrieb. Es ist ein geiler Antrieb, so du stehst morgen eher aus dem Bett auf, wenn du einfach sagst, komm, jetzt krieg das hier. Ich weiss gar nicht mehr, das ist der Boden hier, das ist diese Bretter, man denkt die ganze Zeit. Es ist komisch, es ist merkwürdig, da ist auch ein Kreuz geklebt. Was wurde tatsächlich, ihr könnt euch vielleicht vorstellen, was hinter unserem Poster ist, was da immer noch hängt seit 100 Jahren. Das ist fast ein Hakenkreuz, es ist so halb, es ist so beim Rausgehen hat Goebbels noch mal ein paar Sachen geklebt. Das war so sein Entwurf, ich finde das schöner. Das war der erste Entwurf meines Hakenkreuzes. Wie sieht der zweite Entwurf aus? Drei Striche einfach. Weird. Weirder Ort. Ganz komischer Ort, stimmt schon. Ich finde auch immer diese Neonazi-Hakenkreuz immer so gut, die da immer so ein bisschen was wegtut, damit es nicht ganz so aussieht. Oder so drei, oder du machst dann ein Viereck drum oder drehst es so halb. Ich fand die Aktion gut, wo man die übermalt hat, mit so Haus vom Nikolaus und so. Ja? Was ist los mit dir heute? Du willst heute einfach die Welt verändern. Ja, ein bisschen schon. Ich hätte Lust, irgendwas rumgehen zu lassen, aber ich weiß nicht genau was. Lass mal dein Mikrofon rumgehen und der Abend ist vorbei.
Ja genau, aber jeder nur eine Sekunde.
Also grossartig.
Dinge, die nicht funktionieren.
Tatsächlich, ein Freund von mir hat mein Referat gehalten über das Parfüm.
Okay, immer noch das Referatsthema. Und da ging es um Gerüche und dann hat er eine Rosenblüte rumgehen lassen, damit alle mal dran riechen.
Das war nicht schlecht.
Und man denkt, what the fuck, jeder hat schon mal eine Rose gerochen.
Und natürlich, nach dem zwanzigsten Schüler war die total abgefingert und roch nur noch nach jugendlichen Nasen.
Vielen Dank. Das war nicht schlecht. Und man denkt, what the fuck, jeder hat schon mal eine Rose gerochen. Und natürlich, nach dem zwanzigsten Schüler war die total abgefingert und roch nur noch nach jugendlichen Nasen.
Ich hätte mal einen Korken rumgehen lassen im Referat.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr warum.
Ich glaube, das Referat war die Stimme.
Moment, die Stimme?
Die Stimme. Wie? Stimme halt. Also nicht ein Buch, das heisst die Stimme, sondern einfach the voice. Das war ein Biologienreferat, the voice. Die Stimme. Ein Referat über the voice. Das ist jetzt klarer geworden. Ja, ich glaube ja. So und die Stimme und da ging es darum, dass glaube ich, unser Sprechen kommt aus dem Husten, nämlich eigentlich. Früher haben Menschen nur gehustet. Ja, die anderen Tattler haben nicht gesprochen, erst, irgendwann, aber die haben halt gehustet, weil es halt wichtig war, um die ganzen... Könnt ihr mich ausreden lassen, bevor ihr lacht über meine Unwissenheit? Direkt neben der Autobahn gewohnt und da ist einfach viel Abgase. Ohne Scheiss, der ganze Feinstaub so. Und es war wichtig, um Krankheiten rauszubekommen aus der Lunge und Infektionen und sowas. Und dann hustet man als Mensch erst und dann daraus kann man, oh, oh, oh, hi. Weißt du, deswegen, das war, hi, ich bin Marco, oh, okay. Und wenn du jetzt sagst, recherchiert, hast du dir das einfach ausgedacht oder wo kam das jetzt einfach, klingt, klingt, klingt, pausin. Ja, woher soll man wissen, wie Referate funktionieren. Erstmal denkt doch jeder, es doch selber Dinge ausdenken.
Und das Niesen kommt dann wieder vom Sprechen. Das ist dann der Kreislauf sich dann beendet einfach.
Ja, richtig, und es ist wirklich wahr.
Ich habe das Gefühl, hier wird irgendwann auch der Nobelpreis abgerollen.
Weil er irgendwann angefangen hat, so weird Dinge zu behaupten.
Mir wird das Studio Hamburg Nahrungspreis aberkannt, weil er behauptet, dass man erst gehustet und dann gesprochen hat. Wow, wir sind arrogant auch, der Gag. Nee, das kannst du schon, das ist kein Problem, dass du das alle 20 Minuten erlässt, dass du den Studio in Hamburg-Förderpreis gewonnen hast. Das ist nicht so catchy zu sagen wie ein Grammy. Das ist vielleicht ein Feedback für den Preis. Das stimmt. Du hast ja vorhin vorgeschlagen, dass man generell Worte kürzen sollte. Weil wir haben nicht so viel Zeit, wir leben in der schnellliebenden Welt, wir reden hier schon den ganzen Tag so für diese scheiss Generalisierungen, dass man Worte abkürzen soll, sondern statt Wochenende, Wochenende. Wochenende. Wochenende. Warum sagt man nicht Wochenende? Ja, du ich finde es, mich hast du als Fan. Vergiss die mal kurz, die gar nichts mit anfangen können. Ich bin nur bei dir. Wochenende, ich finde. Wochenende. Man schreibt doch auch direkt Wochenende. Man schreibt erst mal falsch. Das Wort Wochenende sieht doch falsch ausgeschrieben. Zu viele Ends, Ends. Wochenende. Oder einfach länger. Wochenende. Lass uns da noch 50 Minuten drüber sprechen. Nur über dieses Bit. Ich dachte immer, als früher Leute cool waren und WI geschrieben haben, dachte ich immer, es heißt Weekend. Und dachte ich immer, die sind richtig cool, die nutzen englische Begriffe, bis irgendwann mal später in der Nacht um drei Uhr morgens, Wochenende, fuck, einfach und ich muss alles nochmal neu denken. Ja, die sagen nicht Weekend. Ich wache mittlerweile ganz oft in der Nacht auf, ich bin durch, ich bin komplett wahnsinnig geworden, ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, ich baue auch ab, ich baue richtig ab. Ja, dein Gesicht ist so ein bisschen eingefallen alles. Ja, man merkt einfach so, also du bist ja, du denkst ja eigentlich, dass du im Laufe deines Lebens immer besser wirst, oder? Ja. Also du hast das Gefühl so, ich lerne, naja, schon, glaube ich. Also du wirst besser, du lernst mehr, du machst Erfahrungen. Und irgendwie, glaube ich, hat man, also wenn du jetzt in die Zukunft denkst, denkst du nicht, ja, ich werde irgendwann ein kompletter Depp sein, kompletter Arschloch. Du denkst du, du wirst dich irgendwie weiterentwickeln. Aber ich zweifle da mittlerweile dran. Ich habe das Gefühl, vor zwei, drei Jahren war ich besser. Ja, das habe ich aber auch. Ich vergesse mittlerweile so viele Sachen. Total, ich baue ab. Ich war jetzt im Hotel und dann ist das Allerwichtigste bei mir im Hotel immer, dass man nach außen hängt, dieses Bitte nicht stören denkt. Ja. Und irgendwie hatte ich einen kompletten Aussetzer im Kopf und da war dann so eine Mineralwasserflasche. Und die hast du rausgestellt. Die Mineralwasserflasche. Und dass du mein Mädchen denkst, was will er mir sagen? Lecker. Will er mehr zu trinken? Und um diese Mineralwasserflasche war dann auch so ein Etikett oben drauf, das auch so ein Ring war und so ein Pappding und da stand drauf zu ihrer Erfrischung. 3,80. Und ich wirklich in so einem kompletten Aussetzer einfach nehme das und hänge es außen an die Tür hin.
Aber nichts sagt mehr, du willst nicht wissen, was da gerade in diesem Zimmer vorgeht, bitte nicht stören. Und im Rückblick tut es mir so wahnsinnig leid, weil der Zimmerservice tut mir so leid, die geht, ah ok, gut, hier muss ich rein, hier muss ich rein und hier zu ihrer Erfrischung. Und du denkst dir, was heißt das jetzt, was soll das sein? Ist das Ding, das in dem Hotel passiert, wo wir jetzt drin sind? Ja, ja. Und dann tatsächlich heute Morgen...
Das Wasser kostet 7,80 Euro oder so. Ja, das sowieso, das sowieso. Und dann kam die Person rein, hat wahrscheinlich irgendwie lange sich überlegt, was soll ich jetzt machen, was soll ich machen, hat dann an der Zentrale Zimmer Service in Brüssel angerufen und so, was sind die Regeln, was sind die Regeln, ja, gehen Sie rein. Was ist das Protokoll, gehen Sie rein, kein Problem, gehen Sie rein. So spricht man im Brüssel. Gehen Sie rein, kein Problem.
Und dann Tür auf und dann so, ah, Zimmerservice.
und dann ist so, äh, äh, ich will doch nur neues Wasser haben, tiefschlafen, äh, äh, und er so, okay, dann nicht, und dann Tür zu.
Und dann so hat es dann auch noch funktioniert. Aber ich weiss auch nicht, ich habe wirklich diese komplett Aussetzung. Aber es gibt Leute, die einen nur so kennen. Also diese Zimmermädchen, was haben die für ein Bild von der Menschheit eigentlich,
dass die ganze Zeit nur in schlafende Leute reinlaufen, die die ganze Zeit, äh, ne, ne, ich bin noch nicht fertig. Also es ist ja immer, was sagt, man ist ja nicht bereit, irgendwie zu artikulieren, eine Idee zu artikulieren. Vor allem, ich habe mal, da habe ich was gedreht in Köln auch, und dann war ich irgendwie zwei Wochen lang, glaube ich, hatte ich so ein Apartment, und da kam auch wirklich alle drei Tage kam jemand, um die komplett aufzuräumen und ich wollte das aber einfach nicht und dann habe ich erst ein Schild draußen an die Wand geklebt, bitte nicht reinkommen, egal was, trotzdem kam die rein, einfach elf, ich lieg fett groß im Bett, einfach geht wieder und ich habe wirklich angefangen irgendwann so Stühle vor die Tür zu schieben, weil ich mir dachte, ich will einfach nicht da reingesommen und die kam trotzdem rein und macht die Tür auf. Du machst den Job nur, schiebt alles weg einfach durch. Da rennt gerade ein Zimmermädchen weg, den die gerade gemerkt hat, oh shit, ich hätte nicht reingesollt. Und irgendwann habe ich wirklich auch meinen Schlüssel von innen reingesteckt, weil ich mir dachte, jetzt kann niemand mehr reinkommen, die kam trotzdem rein, einfach ich weiß nicht, was es gebraucht hätte, um die dann davon abzulegen. Also Kevin allein zu Hause, so Mechanismen einfach. Genau, so eine Bowlingkugel, die dann so rollt. Aber ich juckt's schon, ne, gleich danach schön Bowlen-Sender. Oh, ihr wollt Bowlen gehen, ne? Wie viele von euch wollen gerade lieber Bowlen gehen, als hier zu sein, ganz im Ernst? Ja, ja. Ihr beiden wart Bowlen gerade? Wirklich? Jetzt gerade? Wow. Aber weil ihr wusstet, wo das hier ist, oder weil ihr dachtet, wir gucken mal, wir hätten doch so viel Zeit, wer hat gewonnen? Man weiss nicht genau, wie Bowling funktioniert, oder? Ich habe auch keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt. Also ohne diesen Rechner, dieses Computer, der etwas ausrechnet, den ich mir wahnsinnig komplex vorstelle, ohne den wüsste ich nicht, wer gewonnen hat. Aber es ist ja verrückt, weil früher war ja wirklich Bowling im Fernsehen wahnsinnig beliebt. Hä? Ich das Volkssport. Ich kenne nur einen Film, in dem es vorkommt, Bicklebowski, das ist alles, was für Bowling war.
Ich glaube, in den 80ern, 70ern, 60ern war es wahnsinnig beliebt in Amerika.
30er-Gerl. Und dann ging es irgendwann, glaubst du, Hitler war auch mal Bowling.
Oh ja. Also wirklich so eine Neonbahn mit so leuchtenden Kugeln.
Also ich probiere das jetzt mal. Ich will gerne mal wissen, so was hat er mal ausprobiert, wo er gemerkt hat, so selbstironisch gemerkt hat, das ist nicht mein Ding. Das ist nicht mein Ding. Gut, Kunst. Aber so, was war noch nicht so so dein Ding? Tischtennis vielleicht nicht. Die Hosen waren zu kurz. Zu kurz. Ich finde es gut, dass niemand von uns Hitler kann. Einfach das, wo den jeder kann, wir können es einfach können es einfach nicht. Zu kurz. Das Ding wie Herbert Grönemeyer bei mir. Waller, Waller lebt. Waller lebt? Waller lebt, wie in dem Song Mensch. Wir können nicht Impressions, das ist etwas, was wir nicht kennen. Nicht schlecht. Was ist deine beste Impression? Ich glaube, es ist dann doch noch Werner Herzog. Ich bin eines Morgens aufgewacht und konnte Werner Herzog spielen. Und dann so, yes, ich kann eine Impression. Oh wow, danke schön. Dann applauselst du Werner Herzog oder für den Typen, der zu spät kommt. Ja. Aber ich versuche dagegen zu arbeiten. Ich baue ab, aber ich versuche dagegen zu arbeiten. Und ich will mich jetzt auch kulturell bilden. Und Werner Herzog ist ein gutes Beispiel, weil es gibt ja Streaming-Plattformen, die sind so für den normalen, Abend nach Hause kommen, abschalten, Netflix an und dann guckst du mittelmässige Rom-Com an irgendwie und dann passt das schon. Aber es gibt ja auch andere Streaming-Plattformen für die krassen Leute. Es gibt zum Beispiel Mubi und die zeigen nur super abgefuckte Arzi-Farzi-Filme und du denkst ja einfach, krass, gucke ich mir an, ich werde ein neuer Mensch, ich bin da drin und die die haben immer 30 Filme und wenn ein neuer kommt, da kommt jeden Tag ein neuer Film und dann fällt einer hinten raus, neuer Film, der schubst den so raus. So, das sind meine Bits und Beiz, weg, dann bist du ja weg. Und da dachte ich mir einfach so, nee, jetzt auch mal kulturell so ein Pierre de Gerdin und... Und guckst die ganze Zeit, die Held und die Steine erweisen und wenn es dann weggeschubst wird vom Werner Herzog-Film, dann sagst du, okay, deabonniert. Und dann habe ich mir den Werner Herzog-Film angeguckt und ich habe einfach gemerkt, das ist nichts für mich. Und das Konzept von diesem Film war, dass sämtliche Schauspieler waren hypnotisiert während des Films. Die wurden hypnotisiert und denen wurde einfach eingebläut, dass die diese Person sind. Also die haben jetzt nicht den König gespielt, sondern die dachten wirklich, dass sie der König sind durch Hypnose. Und ich stelle mir vor, wie, also weider Film ist natürlich extrem weider Film, man versteht fast nichts. Wie gern ich gerade Star Wars nachdrehen würde, mit Fans, denen man einredet, du bist Chewbacca. Aber es ist ja eine geniale Idee, weil du kannst ja dann schauen, wenn es gelingt, dann ist Hollywood ja revolutioniert, weil du brauchst Schauspieler nicht. Du überzeugst Leute einfach nur so nie, du bist Anne Frank einfach. Vergiss Emma Stone einfach. Ja, du kannst singen jetzt einfach. Du bist Anne Frank, wow. Naja, wie ich dachte, hier thematisch. Hier heute? Thematisch. Aber der Film ist super strange und man checkt überhaupt nichts, aber ich schämme die Dreharbeit. Man schämme die Dreharbeit. Ich schämme die Dreharbeit. Aber wie sind die Dialoge? Sind die nicht alle so ein bisschen träge? Weil ich denke mir immer vor, hypnotisiert ist immer so ein bisschen Halbschlaf. Nee, gar nicht, ganz im Gegenteil. Die reden so wie wir jetzt. Vielleicht sind wir jetzt hypnotisiert. Es kann auch sein, vielleicht bin ich du und du bist ich, obwohl ich nur andersrum hypnotisiert. Vielleicht. Oder einer von uns sitzt da unten gerade und denkt noch, in meinem Körper. Können wir mal ganz kurz einen Applaus für die Person, ganz links, ganz hinten, letzter Platz, letzter Platz, Applaus. Ah, die ist so scheiße, da sitzt gar niemand, da sitzt niemand, doch vielleicht doch. Ich glaube, da sitzt jemand, verkriegt sich unter dem Stuhl. Ist immer so hell. Aber es war auf jeden Fall ein Mega-Stranger-Film, super durch. Da ist eine Lüftung an den Gang, ganz kurz. Warum? Hat die jetzt irgendwer angemacht? Ich weiß nicht, es ist ein bisschen zu warm geworden währenddessen. Das ist Stefan auch der schlechteste Detektiv der Welt, aber guckt Sie das mal so kurz an. Was ist das Leiche? Ja, okay. Gut, geht schon. Geht schon. Geht schon. Toll. Bitte. Auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, es war ein wahnsinnig Wunderdreh, weil wenn du jemandem wirklich einbläust, dass er König ist, kannst du ja nicht mit dem beim Catering stehen und sagen, wie wollen sie die Bohnen oder die Oliven oder so. Wenn der wirklich denkt, er ist ein König, kannst du mit ihm ja nicht umgehen. Du kannst ja mit dem nicht normale Gespräche von dem Anweisungen geben. Aber das Bier ist ja, er hat ja trotzdem das Gedächtnis von ihm jetzt und dieses Wissen von ihm jetzt, er kann keinen König spielen, weil nur wenn du ihm hypnotisiert und ihm sagst, du bist König, er erinnert trotzdem noch, er ist Werner aus Duisburg. Ich weiß es nicht, er denkt halt, er ist ist König Werner aus Duisburg. Das ist ein wahnsinnig langweiliger Film, dann sagt er, oh dieses, ich liebe aus dem Rewe da, Regal 13, das will ich jetzt... Den müssen wir erobern, wir müssen Penny erobern. Da haben die diese Nudeln, diese guten Eiernudeln, die will ich haben. Ich meine, deine Idee ist ja trotzdem das gleiche vom Leben. Ja, es stimmt schon, ich weiss aber auch nicht, ob man, also Hypnose kann ich mir eh nicht erklären, finde ich eh super strange. Ist es eigentlich echt? Ja, ich glaube schon irgendwo, aber ich weiss nicht, ich kenne nur diese Darren Brown-Filme. Ja, diese Zauberstein, Dan Brown. Ja, Dan Brown. Die sind auch so gedreht. Tom Hanks weiss bis heute nicht, dass er diese Filme gespielt hat. Aber der heisst, wahrscheinlich ist es Dieter, der denkt nur, er ist Tom Hanks, aber er ist tatsächlich Dieter. Aber glaubst du, es gibt irgendwann noch mal Könige? Glaubst du, ist es so, dass man sagt, man geht noch mal, sagt doch mal, jetzt, wir haben alles ausprobiert, wir hatten jetzt jede Idee im Buch, so alles hat nicht funktioniert, immer kamen Arschlöcher an die Macht, lass uns einmal noch König probieren, einmal noch, einmal, dann höre ich auf, dann höre ich auf, lass einmal noch probieren.
Diese Lehrerin, die dieses Experiment gemacht hat und die Nico verprügelt haben nach 20 Minuten, ich denke mir, ja, es wird noch mal irgendwann Könige geben, Menschen sind einfach so gebaut. Meinst du? Ja, davon bin ich fest überzeugt. Es gab tatsächlich mal, ich war mal in meinen Jugendjahren in eine junge Dame verliebt, und je mehr ich mit ihr gesprochen habe, habe ich gemerkt, dass sie unfassbar dumm ist. Ja, Frauen.
Boah, sehr gut. Das ist ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz falsch, da zu lachen. Leute!
Und es ist ja blöd, es ist eine komische Situation, weil du bist ja, also sag ich mal, so Verliebtheiten sind ja irrational.
Du kannst ja nicht einfach sagen, pass auf, die ist total bescheuert, hör auf, aber du bist ja trotzdem noch nicht so verliebt und du redest immer mehr mit ihr und denkst ja irgendwann, es wird immer schlimmer und die irgendwann wirklich einfach gesagt hat, nee, ich denke, Deutschland ging es besser, wenn es wieder einen König gäbe. Und du so, ja? Und ich so, oh, Leute, scheiße, vielleicht verbringe ich den Rest meines Lebens mit dieser Frau, man kann sich das ja nicht aussuchen. Wenn man wirklich verliebt ist, kann man sich das ja nicht aussuchen. Das ist nicht, wie das Leben funktioniert. Naja. Über dem Leben steht nicht groß, du kannst es dir ja nicht aussuchen. Ich glaube nicht, dass du dir aussuchen kannst, in wen du dich verliebst. Nee, aber du kannst ja aussuchen, ob du mit jemandem zusammenkommst, mit dem du verliebt bist. Boah, das ist aber auch eine schwierige Ecke. Ja gut, aber du kannst ja nicht jemandem zusammenbleiben und dann denkst du dir immer in deinem Leben, ach Mensch, die Rita, die war so dumm und ich liebe sie trotzdem. Aber ganz kurz, Liebe und Sex sind ja was anderes. Ja, ich rede ja auch nicht. Ich rede ja auch nicht über Sex. Ja, aber verliebt sein, ist es nicht in so einem pubertierenden Sinne eher so ein Crush haben auf? Ja, aber trotzdem kannst du es ja nicht ändern. Du kannst ja immer wieder sagen, Gehirn, pass auch mal auf, folgende Gründe. Aber es war schon so ein, du wolltest wieder zusammen sein. Es war nicht, du wolltest dich mal... Ja, das ist ja immer so ein vages Gefühl, das keinen Zielpunkt hat. Das ist ja einfach nur so ein und dann aber kein, aber kein Satz. Das ist glaube ich Natur in a nutshell. Ja. Dinge, die man nicht, es tut ein bisschen weh, ist alles so ein paar Haken. Ja, keine Ahnung, ich habe nur bis zu dem Punkt gedacht. Aber das war auch so, wo ich mir dachte, ich kann nicht weiter mit der Person reden, weil je mehr sie sagen, desto dümmer wird sie. Und desto dümmer werde auch ich.
Ja, oder ich denke mir, vielleicht liegt es an mir.
Was macht sich heute?
Ich weiss nicht.
Vorstand der AfD.
Oh, der macht fast.
Oh, der gut gut.
Boah, ich glaube, wenn wir so Satire machen, wir wären nicht gut.
So politische Satire.
Ich glaube, wir wären überhaupt nicht gut.
Nee.
Ich weiß nicht, was aus der geworden ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Kann ich dir auch nicht sagen.
Also ich über Weihnachten...
Nenn mal, Rita!
Rita!
Ich wollte nur sagen, dass...
Also, ich finde dich echt super so.
Warum ist das so eine abgekapselte... Warum ist das so ein fucking Junggesellnenabschied? Die wollen eigentlich nur einen entspannten Bartag haben. Von dir sieht es aus, als ob ihr Gefängnisinsassen seid, die man in den Bus gesetzt hat und so, ihr habt immer Spaß. Aber sie sind trotzdem noch im Gefängnis. Ne, die wollten bowlen, aber haben sich einfach in der Tür geirrt. Sie wollten mit Feisager-Cabuzzi bowlen. Denken sie, wann kommen die Kugeln, wann kommen endlich diese riesigen Kugeln. Ich war einmal bowlen und mir war jede einzelne Kugel zu schwer. Jede einzelne Kugel war mir zu schwer. Und ich sag, die ist ja ein bisschen schwer, nimm doch die, die Kinderkugel. ich hieb sie hoch und denk mir, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, die ist mir auch so schwer. Bowling ist kein grosser Bestandteil meines Lebens, aber trotzdem fällt mir einmal im Monat auf, dass ich eine unfassbare Angst davor habe, eine Bowlingkugel mit zu kleinen Löchern in der Hand zu haben. Oh ja. Und dann wirst du die los und die klingt noch an dir dran und die reisst die Finger aus. Diese Angst habe ich, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum ich diese Angst habe, ich gehe ja nicht bowlen. aber ich habe diese Angst, dass man diese, dass man dann, ohhh, ne ganz schrecklich, oder nicht, man hat diese Angst. Das ist ja auch die klassische Bowlerhand, wo einfach die drei Finger in der Mitte fehlen, so weiß man die tatsächlich, bei den antiken Ägyptern, weiss man ja, wer Bowling gespielt hat und wer nicht, einfach die drei, es gibt auch einen Gott, dem fehlen diese drei Finger, den Bowling-Gott, Bowling, David Bowling. Sehr gut, nicht schlecht, Leute, nicht glatschen, nicht Leute. Ja, ich weiss nicht genau, wie Bowling funktioniert. Ich habe auch ewig nicht verstanden, ich dachte, die Physik in Bowling-Hallen wäre eine andere, bis ich verstanden habe, dass die Bahn geölt ist und deswegen dreht die sich. Ich dachte mir, was ist in diesem Teufelszeug drin? Aber es gibt diesen geilen Channel,'s Inside. Ein Vater und sein Sohn machen den Channel What's Inside auf YouTube, wo die einfach Dinge aufschneiden. Und die haben sich auch überlegt, eine Bodengugel aufzuschneiden und zu gucken, was da drin ist. Und es ist dann unspektakulär. Meistens ist der Titel des Videos spannender als alles andere, aber mittlerweile gibt es den Channel nicht mehr. Und das letzte Video ist What's Inside My Son. Das ist das Problem, irgendwann fällt dir nichts mehr ein. Die sind halt zum Arzt gegangen und hat denen erklärt, was in seinem Sohn ist. Menschensachen, also haben dann den DNA-Typen gefragt und gesagt, ihr weisser Sohn ist ein sehr cleverer Mensch. Aber tatsächlich haben die nicht aufgeschnitten. Ich glaube, es ist schwierig, wenn du mal so ein Konzept anfängst, irgendwann kommst du nicht mal weiter. Man hat so alles aufgeschnitten, was gibt, und du kommst nicht mehr weiter. Irgendwann schneidest du ein Mikrofon auf oder irgendwas, kommst nicht weiter. Irgendwann kam dann der Vater so ins Wohnzimmer und hat gesagt, du weisst, was heute dran ist. Wir hatten schon alles durch. Es ist die moderne Abraham oder so ein Typ, die moderne Abraham. Ja, ich verstehe, Isaac. Ja, Isaac, genau. Isaac musste sterben. Früher opfert man es Gott und heute opfert man es YouTube. Da bin ich zu Hause, Bibelreferenzen. Ist nicht YouTube so eine Art Gottheit heutzutage? Oh Gott, wir sind so furchtbar unangenehm heute. Sind nicht YouTuber so eine Art Heiligen? Oder schon, oder nicht? Verdammt nochmal, ich krieg das mit dem Populismus nicht so hin, wie geht das? Das Herz des Volkes packen einfach mal so. Ist nicht Likes heute sowas wie Geld? Scheiße. Gelächter. Ich finde aber auch gut, wenn man Propaganda versucht, aber Gelächter erntet. Ja, das stimmt. Und man denkt, mach halt das. Ich glaube, die meisten Comedians fangen auch als Möchtegern Diktatoren an, die irgendwann merken, hey, das funktioniert auch ganz gut, mach ich einfach so weiter. Sind nicht Likes sowas wie Geld und Leute pf, wo man denkt, Stand-up-Termin. Zack. Als ich über Weihnachten zu Hause war, ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber es ist immer toll, in die Heimat zu kommen und so. Und mir ist mittlerweile aufgefallen, meine Heimatstadt ist wie, ich habe dann auch, muss man sagen, die drei Herr-der-Ringe-Filme wieder geguckt, weil ich die Heimatstadt wieder geguckt habe. Mir ist aufgefallen, meine Heimatstadt ist Mittelerde, Carmen ist Mittelerde, weil es gibt, muss man sagen, es gibt verschiedene Orte und die passen sehr gut. Ich komme aus Südkamen. Südkamen hat normale Altbau-Ecken, alles ganz nett. Und diese riesigen Elefanten. Und diese riesigen Elefanten, auf denen ich immer morgens zur Schule geritten bin.
Und er hat aber auch so sehr snobartige Siedlungen als Neuper und so.
Klar, die Elben.
Wir waren auch alle irgendwie ein bisschen grösser, wir hatten alle weiße, lange Haare, so und wir waren Elben. Und es gibt keine einzige schwarze Person. Es gibt keine schwarze Person, Gott sei Dank. Und dann, tatsächlich gab's dann nebenan, gab's Carmen Medler und Medler, das sindwehr-Jungs, die Dorf-Jungs, die überall bei der Feuerwehr, die trinken alle ein bisschen gerne, die heißen alle Schmalfussens und so. Das ist einfach das Auenland. Dann ist es überall fahren Dreck herum und dann alles mit seiner Kutsche und so, das hat total gepasst. Dann gibt es noch so eine Art schlimmes Mädler, wo dann alle so Zwergen-ähnliche Sachen schon einnehmen, also wo der Alkohol schon ein bisschen mehr Bestandteil der Woche einnimmt als nur das Wochenende. Und dann gibt's Bergkarm, und Bergkarm ist fucking Mordor, weil man muss sagen, Frauke Petry kommt aus Mordor, also aus Bergkarm. Es passt alles zusammen, es ist eine große Stadt, und dann kam Mitte ist so Gondor, wo alle alle sind, Arschlöcher, die sind nette Leute. Wer bist du? Ich bin ein Elb. Ein Elb. Ich bin irgendein Elb. Ich bin nicht der Elb. Du bist so der Elb im Hintergrund. Der stirbt. Der Elb, der im Hintergrund die Fans sieht. Der vom Urukeige Köpfe, das bist du. Der Elb nicht. Das ist dein Ding. Auch bei Herr der Ringe live im Konzert war richtig cool, weil dann gibt es am Ende diese grosse Schlacht, wo die ganze Zeit ein Kinderchor singt und bei Hellringe live war dann ein grosser, grosser Kinderchor und alle singen dann diese tolle Elbenmusik. Und im Hintergrund werden einfach Orks geköpft die ganze Zeit. Die ganze Zeit, vum, vum und Blut fliegt durch die Köpfe und dann ist dieser fromme Kinderchor, steht da vorne auf dieser Leinwand und singt diese Melodie. Von einem Film, den sie nicht mal gucken dürfen eigentlich. Ja, egal was passiert, dreht euch nicht um. Dreht euch niemals um, guckt nach vorne und singt, singt, liebe Kinder. Ich schaue tatsächlich auch mal Herr der Ringe, und vor allem auch die Extended Edition, die ist fucking lang und lang. Und vor allem, so Star Wars gibt es ja immer dieses Ding, so A wurde im Schnitt gerettet. Ich weiss nicht, ob das für Herr der Ringe nicht auch ein bisschen, bisschen auch zustimmt, weil ich finde, da sind einige ziemlich schwachsinnige Entscheidungen drin in der Extended Edition mit den Bonusszenen, nämlich Frodo und Sam Zin aus dem Auenland, ja, irgendwie das erste Mal in ihrem gesamten Leben gehen sie auf ein Abenteuer, irgendwie dann diese Szene, so weit war ich noch nie vom Auenland entfernt, los geht's, wunderbar, krass, was erweite uns in der Welt, und was ist das allererste, was Sie sehen, das allererste, was Sie sehen, das allererste, was Sie sehen, das allererste Also das allerkrasseste High Fantasy, super übernatürliche Wesen, die jetzt irgendeine Art von Transzendenz gehen. Das ist das allererste, was Sie sehen. Wo eigentlich beide so voll sagen müssten, okay, tau, ich bin raus. Und das ist das erste, was ja da natürlich total unklug ist, weil du willst ja, dass es sich irgendwie so aufbaut. Du siehst mal erst, dann siehst du so einen bösen Geist. Sag dir toll, was für Quatsch geschrieben wird. Dann siehst du Aragorn, der noch Streicher ist, der noch ein normaler Typ ist. Du weißt noch gar nicht, dass der auch ein Halbgott ist oder so. Und dann geht es immer weiter. Und dann irgendwann siehst du erst die Elben und denkst dir, wow, krass. Und deswegen fände ich auch gut geschnitten, muss ich an der Stelle sagen, also falls der Cutter von Herr der Linge hier im Saal ist, gute Arbeit, gut gemacht, ansonsten. Aber Tolkien hat ja alles für sich geschrieben, das finde ich auch ganz lustig eigentlich, dem die mir mehr zum Veröffentlichen auch gezwungen. Er hat ja primär einfach so eine Abhandlung über Sprachen auch geschrieben und hat manche Dinge gar nicht übersetzt. Okay, aber du erfindest nicht eine Sprache, ohne dass du das...
Das ist ja Tolkien auf einer Party, der dann so...
Übrigens, eine Sprache erfunden.
Also das Gespräch, das ihr jetzt gerade über Tinder haben würdet, klänge...
L'Ordreline, da la Savondon.
Da la Savondon. Okay, cool, Tolkien, danke, alles klar.
Okay, und er so, nur by the way, mit kompletter Grammatik und Vokabular auch noch.
Klar, und dann so, okay, dann veröffentlich es doch.
Veröffentlich, nein, Quatsch, niemals, niemals, Quatsch. Ich so, wir haben uns verheiratet gerade. Oh, mit dem Ring? Ja. Folgendes ist so fucking J-R-R. Kurzer Elevator-Bitch. Und dann so, veröffentlich es doch. Och, Quatsch, das ist doch viel zu schlecht, um es zu veröffentlichen. Ich glaube, so ein Arschloch war Tolkien. So einer war Tolkien, wo alle so, halt einfach die Fresse und veröffentlich es einfach. Wie viel Wissen hast du darüber, dass es gerade fundiert? 40 Prozent. Okay, das reicht mir völlig aus. Gute, hohe 40 Prozent, saftige, 30... Heute abtet er noch nichts mehr als 40 Prozent. Dichtgepackte 40 Prozent. Sehr gut. Ab wann entscheidet man, dass man sich so J-R-R... Nee weil vor allem also jetzt mal einen kleinen ein exkurs in mein persönliches Privatleben ich heisse ja Florentin Pascal David Will, das heisst ich könnte mich auch FDP Will nennen. Das heisst in irgendeinem Moment meines Lebens kann ich die Entscheidung treffen, ich nenne mich jetzt FDP-Will, weil du kannst ja auch sagen, wie J.R.R. Tolkien, bist du FDP-Will. Und ich sag mal so, falls irgendwann mal ein Bundeskanzlerplatz frei wird, ich sag Leute, wählt mich FDP-Will für die Grünen, wer hat mich dann einfach Bundeskanzler. Gebt mir alle Stimmen. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ich finde das so interessant, auch diese Mittelnamen so irgendwie, Samuel L. Jackson. Samuel L. Jackson. J.K. Rowling. Ja, schwieriger macht, als es nötig ist. Ja, stimmt. Die heißt J.K. Rowling, weil der Verleger nicht zugetraut hat, dass Leute so viel kaufen von einer Frau, dass Leute von einer Frau eine Fantasygeschichte haben. Aber interessanterweise musste es die Twilight-Autorin auch noch machen. Nach dem Erfolg von Harry Potter. Wie heisst sie denn nochmal? Die Twilight-Bella. Jacob Bella Tricks is Strange. Ich weiss nicht, wie sie heisst, aber die geht auch nur unter ihrem Vornamen ab. Weisst es irgendwer? Alle wissen es lächelig. Stefan, wirklich? Schleppern, ne, ne, komm, meine komplette Theorie fällt. Ich weiss, das ist seit zehn Minuten. Nee, die hat doch ... Nee, aber dann Fifty Shades, wer hat der was geschrieben? James! Ja genau, wie noch mal ... Weisst du, irgendwas nicht? Was ist die Hauptstadt von Botswana? So, da hab ich sie. Bots, Botsdrop. Botswana City. Also, so, die Fifty Shades of Grey Autorin konnte nicht Wir lösen es erst in den nahmen 80 Minuten. Ich weiß es nicht, genau. Ich finde es langsam, also wenn man es bewusst wird, dass das Publikum gegenüber sitzt, von allem, es ist schon unangenehm, dass man so viele Dinge nicht weiß. Wir reden so viel Quatsch und einer weiß es immer besser. Das ist mindestens einer hier, der die ganze Zeit denkt, boah, ich glaube aber, dasse, es sind immer andere. Ich glaube aber, dass viele Leute einfach auch noch dümmer sind und sich denken, oh zum Glück bin die, die höre ich so dumm. Und deswegen kommen sie immer gerne und sagen so, ach da kann ich mir Leute angucken, die noch dümmer sind und dann fühle ich mich wieder gut. Das ist ja so ein bisschen die Idee. Schaust du nicht auch manchmal so Verschwörungstheorie-Videos, so Flat-Earth-Videos und denkst dir einfach, die sind so dumm? Und dann einfach um dich gut zu fühlen. Ja, ja, es fängt so an, danach endet es immer mit einem Schild, vielleicht ist auch alles flach. Verdammt, ihr haben Recht. Stimmt, wenn ich ein Glas Wasser habe, ist die Wasseroberfläche völlig gerade. Ihr könnt gar nicht in der Kugel leben. Und Newton so, oh scheiße, stimmt. Fuck! Fuck, du hast völlig Recht, du hast nie ein Glas Wasser in da. Ich hätte neulich den Film geguckt von Damien Giselle, First Man. Und ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit, was wenn wir nicht auf dem Mond waren. Das ist die ganze Geschichte für den Arsch. Und es gibt gute Beweise dafür, dass wir nicht auf dem Mond waren. Erklär mir noch einmal, wenn du es mir erklärst, sind sie immer so plausibel, und dann gucke ich diese Videos und dann sagen die mir, aber die Fahne weht und da ist kein Wind und ich denke mir, ja, ja, ja, ja, erklär mir nochmal, warum wir auf dem Mond waren. Naja, der Mond, der bewegt sich ja mit einer gewissen Geschwindigkeit und deswegen hast du Fahrtwind, weil der ja so zipt, so richtig kippt. Nein, du hast keinen Wind in der atmosphäre. Und deswegen müsstest du dir sich auch immer festhalten, sonst fliegen die weg, die Astronauten, außer du bist auf der Schattenseite. Und diese Theorie, dass die ganzen Schatten in verschiedene Richtungen gehen? Nee, die Sonne ist ja woanders beim Mond, deswegen hast du auch die Schatten woanders. Ja, aber die gehen in verschiedene Richtungen, aber du hast doch nur eine Sonne. Ja, ja, das wird schon. Aber die sind ja auch, das ist ja durch die Perspektive des Fotos oft. Des Studios vielleicht, verschiedene Studi Studiolichter. Ja, ja, ja, oder halt wegen, ah, vielleicht, wo du das sagst, eigentlich, ich meine, man kann schon mal drüber nachdenken eigentlich. Man hätte das schon gut machen können. Vielleicht gab es das nicht, vielleicht gab es die Mutter noch nie. Gibt es irgendeine Verschwörungstheorie, an du die glaubst? Also ich meine, es gibt ja auch ganz, ganz viele, und die können ja nicht alle falsch sein. Also allein statistisch gesehen muss ja irgendwie diese Eidechsen, vielleicht ist die wahr.
Eine muss ja wahr sein, dass irgendwie Obama eine Eidechse ist oder so, und man sagt statistisch gesehen.
Ist eine von 100 Millionen weirden Theorien recht.
Ich würde ja jetzt sagen, dieser amerikanische Holocaust an den Südkoreanern und Nordkoreanern, aber da habe ich sehr viele negative Kommentare bekommen im Netz, als ich das erzählt habe. Das war ein großer Fehler, das in der Hauptstadt der Toleranz Köln zu präsentieren. Hamburg, das wäre ich angetan. Aber ja, stimmt schon. Ich glaube, es gibt verschiedene Verschwörungen, gerade was so Licht angeht. Ich glaube, man sagt uns da nicht die ganze Wahrheit. Ich glaube, viele haben da noch keine Ahnung. Und ich glaube, irgendwann kommt noch mal raus, so irgendwie das war am Ende. Das ist das gleiche wie Ton, nur halt mit einer anderen Farbe oder so. Und dann sagen alle, ja, jetzt gibt's auch Sinn. Ich glaube, irgendwas ist da noch hinter der Ecke. Ich glaube, da... Bei Licht jetzt? Ja, bei Licht. Licht sind verschiedene artige Wellenlängen. Ich glaube, Licht und Ton ist im Grunde dasselbe, nur halt ein bisschen anders. So, hat jemand einen Nobelpreis da? Kann ich ihn direkt nehmen? Kann ich ihn direkt nehmen? Wie hat man dem den Nobelpreis abgenommen? Ist das wirklich jemand da zuhause? Wütend! So, guten Tag, ähm, hey, hey, das ist neuer! Ich weiss nicht, wo der Prozess startet, dass, ähm, so einer Türke auf, guten Tag, ähm, folgendes, ähm, wir müssten leider, leider ihren Nobelpreis wieder zurücknehmen. Wieso? Weil wir gemerkt haben, dass sie ein rassistisches Arschloch sind. Und das ist unangenehm, dass jetzt das von mir kommt, aber... Ja, warum schickt die mir den Scheissschwarzen? Ja, um sie zu taten, ja, nein, ich meine, wir haben es in den Nissen. Man muss dann auch so Was kann so machen, wie bei so einem Kartenspiel, wo man so eine Karte ablegen muss.
Na gut, okay. Nee, und das Lustige ist, das erhe ich mir immer daran ein, der hat seine Medaille schon
versteigert, weil er ja glaube ich, weil er Geldprobleme hatte, weil er ins Huxley-Schooler
nebenan in die Spiele gegangen ist.
Oder kann man das eigentlich machen auf so einem Rolletttisch, so eine Nobelpreismedalie,
so alles auf die Zahl 13, bam!
Ja, das Problem ist ja beim Puckertisch, wie willst du mitziehen?
Wie? Kann man das eigentlich machen auf so einen Roulette-Tisch, so eine Nobelpreis-Medaille, so alles auf die Zahl 13, Bäm!
Ja, das Problem ist ja beim Pokertisch, wie willst du mitziehen?
Wie?
Also, wenn vor dir der DNA-Typ ist und der setzt dann den Nobelpreis hin, so hin, was soll ich dann setzen?
Hä, Roulette, da musst du doch nicht dagegen setzen.
Ich rede gerade von Poker, du scheiße Arschloch.
Ja, ich rede von Roulette.
Aber du kannst, ne, du kannst ja all in gehen einfach.
Also, kommt ein Rassist, Albert Einstein und der Papst in eine Spielotheme. Bleib kurz dran, wir kriegen das hin. Der Nobelpreisträger liegt in der Nobelpreiste auf 13, sagt der Papst, roulette, rien never plus, sagt der Rassist, habe ich nicht verstanden, ich rede nur deuts deutsch. Na guck mal, es geht doch, man muss es nur hart genug wollen. Wir haben nicht gesagt, dass er gut wird, glaube ich. Man muss es nur hart genug wollen. Wie kommen in diese Witzbücher eigentlich rein? So nicht. Wie kann man da anrufen und sagen, ich hätte noch einen, ich habe noch eine Seite frei, deswegen lassen ja viele Bücher hinten die letzten drei Seiten frei, falls der Autor sagt und irgendwie nochmal so und dann nochmal und am Ende lebten alle gut. Das hatte ich jetzt vergessen. Ja, und der hat Holger die ganze Welt gemalt. Ja, du mit deinem scheiß Holger, die Welt gemalt irgendwie. Entschuldigen, wissen Sie, wo es zum Bahnhof geht? Ja, aber falls Sie wissen wollen, wo Mordor ist, hier bei Rohan. Hier, aber gehen Sie bei Helms-Klamm an links. Wo Helms-Klamm? Ich glaube, du hast schon mal mit einer berühmten Person gesprochen, ohne es zu wissen.
Dass du wirklich mal jemanden auf der Strasse fragst, so können sie mir sagen, wo ich bin, und wo der nächste Norma ist, und dann ist es irgendwie Jack Black und du merkst es nicht und der dann so, ja klar, kein Problem hier, kein Problem hier, kein Problem hier, sag ich Ihnen und dann geht das denn und du merkst es gar nicht, gehst nach Hause und denkst dir wow. Ne, das denkst du dann nicht. Wow, was ein geiler Fremd. Du kannst ja aus einem anderen Grund wow kennen. Ja, genau. Ja, ich dachte mir, letztens hat mich vor dem Dom jemand angesprochen und er wollte, dass ich ein Foto von ihm mache, was extrem unangenehm war. Aber in eine andere Richtung, weg vom Dürr. Und vor allem, der hatte so einen Rolli, so einen Trolli. Und der kam mit seinem Trolli aus dem Taxi und dann wollte er dieses Foto machen und sich dafür positionieren. Aber immer in dem Moment, in dem er diesen Trolli losgelassen hat, ist er umgefallen. Und dann ist er weg, ah, er ist ja umgefallen. Dann stelle ich wieder auf und dann fällt er wieder um. Und dann stelle ich wieder auf und ich denke, das wird nichts mehr, ich komme heute nicht mehr nach Hause einfach. Und ich wollte, der war Franzose, und dann kannte ich ihn jetzt nicht, ja, peut-être le trollier, on peut-être le fromage, son paris, einfach irgendwas. Das hat nicht funktioniert. So reden die alle, ne? Bis ich dann irgendwann angefangen habe, ihn festzuhalten, wo ich dachte, er muss jetzt auch nicht unbedingt stehen, aber falls dir das so wichtig ist, dann halte ich ihn fest, er gibt mir sein Handy in die Hand, positioniert sich und ich, während ich festhalte, habe das Handy in der Hand, sehe da auch nochmal, dass er Franzose ist, während dessen rattert mein Gehirn, lass dir bitte irgendeinen coolen französischen Satz einfallen, dass du das jetzt sagen kannst, irgendwas cooles, und mir ist es sich eingefallen und die Bilder waren gottenhässlich, wirklich, er stand direkt neben so einem Scheinwerfer, direkt in die Kamera und ich einfach, oh, oh, Tröbja, Tröbja, einfach 100 Fotos gemacht, nichts gesehen einfach und dann zumindest habe ich es noch auf ein Au revoir bekommen, aber mehr ist mir nicht eingefallen, ich habe zwölf Jahre Französisch gelernt. Wie jetzt? Ne, ich kann mich nur noch erinnern, aber habe ich schon mal erzählt, aber ich finde es großartig, dass wir nach einer Pause zurückkamen, zu spät, in den Französischunterricht und die Französische Lehrerin, die wir wirklich schon seit fünf Jahren haben, und die so, ah, da seid ihr irgendwie so, pardon monsieur, zur Lehrerin. Und dann ging einfach so, ihr lernt seit fünf Jahren Französisch, wo man einfach so merkt, liegt's an mir oder liegt's an euch? Das Schulsystem, Leute, das Schulsystem in Deutschland funktioniert nicht. Ja. Wie toll! Okay. Funktioniert so eigentlich Politik, dass man so Dinge anspielt und was sorgt? Ja, und dann mal gucken, wo die Schwingung im Raum ist und dann in die Richtung beinahe Piks. Ja. Da war ja was, da stösst er auf fruchtbaren Boden. Weniger Flüchtlinge oder mehr Flüchtlinge, okay, ich mach's mal, wenn das Thema sind, genauso viele Flüchtlinge, wie es bis jetzt schon sind. Okay, okay, alles klar, dafür steh ich mit meinem Namen. Auch nicht so gut, dafür steh ich mit meinem Namen, dafür steh ich mit seinem Namen, lieber mal. Du stehst dafür mit meinem Namen, nur dass es weisst. In den nächsten politischen Diskussionen kannst du sagen, so war's. Ich habe einmal, glaube ich, mein Leben eine politische Diskussion geführt, auf irgendeiner Party, wo man dann irgendwie endet, in so einer Ecke. Es ist immer drei Uhr auf einer Party und dann beginnen diese ganzen Diskussionen und man denkt, man sollte jetzt nach Hause gehen oder Politik. Ja, du bist in so einer Diskussion gefangen, wo man plötzlich darüber diskutiert, wer schlimmer war, Hitler oder Stalin. Und aus irgendeinem Grund hatte ich die Stalin-Karte und musste für Stalin...
Diktator-Fights, Walter Rocket Beans TV.
...musten dafür argumentieren und denken mir so, hey, mir gehen die Argumente aus, aber es ist doch egal.
Und irgendwann denkt man sich, ich gehe einfach. Und da denkt man sich, eigentlich kann man die Debatte beenden, indem man einfach geht.
Und ab dann hat mir Politik Spaß gemacht, weil ich mir immer dachte so, ich muss nicht zuhören, ich kann auch einfach gehen.
Man muss aber den polnischen Abgang machen.
Das stimmt. Wie Hitler. Da bin ich sehr gut. Woher kommt das eigentlich? Ist das rassistisch gesagt? Weiß ich nicht genau, weiß ich nicht. Woher kommt polnischer, weißt du es wieder? Die Hauptstadt von Botswana ist Wagadougou, okay? Vor allem polnisch zu machen ist einfach nur ein anderes Wort für Arschloch sein. Weiss jemand, woher das kommt? Oh,stehlen! Oh! Okay. Der Gag kam nicht an. Es gibt immer einen noch grösseren Rassist, wenn wir eins von Qui-Gon Jinn gelernt haben. Schlecht. Na gut, es gibt ihn ein. Ich weiss es nicht. Es kann schon sein, oder? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher. Es ist auch ein bisschen dieses Plakat, dieses symbolhafte Plakat, was hinter uns gross weht. Ja, es ist zu in your face. Es müsste kleiner sein, es müsste wie so eine Briefmarke gross sein. Briefmarke aber dafür näher, dass es einfach so genau vorne in der Luft hängt. Weil Dinge sind ja, wenn du sie kleiner machst, aber näher sind sie genauso gross. Das stimmt. Und dann kannst du eigentlich immer alles gleich machen. Das ist auch Peter Jackson bei den Verfilmungen von J.J.R. Tolkiens Film aufgefallen, deswegen hat er selber damit gespielt. Ich dachte mir immer so, warum gehen Leute ins Kino, wenn man sich nicht einfach näher an den Fernseher setzen kann. Und deswegen ersatzte ich meine, Kinder leben immer ganz nah am Fernseher. Ist doch wie Kino, ich mach keine Freunde. Ja, während irgendwie alle im Kino waren und irgendwie hat mir bis jetzt auch noch niemand erklären können, warum das nicht so ist. Aber ich weiss es nicht, vielleicht keine Ahnung. Ich bin mir auch nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Wer erklärt's ihm? Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher. Am I right? Und dann irgendwann hatte ich so, wir sind halt bei Herr der Ringe, aber ich hatte das Herr der Ringe Spiel auf dem Gameboy Advanced und am Ende, wenn du das Spiel durchgespielt hast, hast du drei Sekunden aus dem Film gesehen, auf deinem fucking Gameboy Advanced. Hast du einen Kinofilm gesehen? Und dann bist du in der Sonne und du denkst... Shit, jetzt muss ich es nochmal durchspielen. Und ich war so weggeblasen davon, dass ich in meinem Bett liege und Gameboy Advance spiele und ich sehe einen Kinofilm auf meinem Gameboy Advance. Das war der schönste Moment meines Lebens, bis heute. Wirklich. Und ich dachte, alles ist möglich. Irgend, irgendwann in unserer Zukunft werden wir Kinofilme im Bett sehen können. Unfassbar. Mit Streaming-Diensten wie Netflix zum Beispiel. Tatsächlich, was das Beste an dem ganzen Bonusmaterial von Herr der Ringe ist, ist das heute Antenne Outland eigentlich, können wir nicht so den Namen noch? Nein, das kommt noch in Ruhe, aber das ist total lustig, weil die haben sich den ganzen Film, weil die mussten ja wirklich mit den Perspektiven spielen, weil Elijah Wood ist nicht wirklich so gross und Sir E. McKellen ist vielleicht schon sehr gross, aber nicht so gross wie in dem Kontrast da ist. Und dann haben die halt die ganze Zeit mit den Kameraperspektiven spielen müssen. Da haben die halt also in dem Original-Set dann schon mal die ganze Szene, haben die vorher gestoryboardet und genau zu wissen, wie lösen die es auf, wo sind die Kameramovements usw. und haben halt die ganze Szene gespielt mit den Original-Kamera-Positionen, aber mit dem Handy gefilmt und mit dem Team als Schauspieler. Und der Typ, der Gandalf gespielt hat, war so ein Producer, der einfach oben drauf so einen Stock hatte und oben drauf war so ein Bild von Ian McKellen.
Und Peter Jackson wollte erst nicht mitspielen, weil er der sein wollte, der mit dem Handy filmt, hat dann so einen Junior Producer dahingesetzt, der die ganze Zeit Frodo spielt. Und es gibt diesen ganzen Anfang des Filmes gibt es, wie schlechte Schauspieler spielen das und Gander ist einfach so ein Stock. Und das Beste ist, dass die nach mehreren Einstellungen gemerkt haben, der Junior-Producer kann einfach nicht spielen. Er kann selbst dafür zu schlecht spielen. Dieser Stock spielt einen besseren Gandalf, als der Typ Frodo spielt. Und dann gibt's einen harten Schnitt und Peter Jackson ist Frodo. Es läuft ganz normal alles durch, die Kameramovements sind alles das gleiche, dann gibt's einen harten Schnitt und es dreht sich nicht mit der Plüsse um, sondern mit der Jackson dreht sich um, hat den Ring in der Hand. Das ist mega gut. Und wenn Sie irgendwann, Sie haben nicht mehr genug Geld, den Film fertig zu drehen, dann denken, fuck it, veröffentliche ich einfach das, scheiss drauf. An den Anfang erinnert sich eh kein Mensch einfach. Niemand interessiert sich für Anfänge vom Film. Ich glaube auch nicht. Aber die hatten ja dann auch alles, alle Teller und sollen noch mal einen kleiner, ne? Ja, ja. Und ich dachte mir immer, so irgendjemand hat die ja alle mit nach Hause genommen. So, alles ist noch kleiner, weil die schmeißt ja nicht einfach weg. Und dann hat irgendjemand zuhause in Neuseeland einen gesamten Haushalt in klein. Und dann kommen Leute zu Besuch und denken sich immer so, irgendwas ist hier anders. Ich kann nicht mein Vater drauf sein. Ich bin riesig. Die Leute, die Feiner, Koeka und Ralf Schmitz denken sich, geil, da will ich wohnen. Einmal fühlen wie ein normaler Mensch. Oh, okay, da ist es. Ich denke, das sind gerade die Namen, die mir einführen, weil wenn man aus Köln nach Berlin fliegt, sitzt man immer mit Comedy-Flieger. Es ist immer Balder, Georg Uecker und heute war ich mit Annette Frier und Simon Gosio im Flugzeug. Wirklich? Ja. Wow. Ja, lustigerweise stand Annette Frier danach in diesem Bus neben mir, wo man dann zum Gate gebracht wird, und sie hatte ihr Handy auf und hat dann die Mails gelesen. Und ich liebe es, fremde Leute Mails zu lesen. Du kannst sie lesen von einem fremden Display? Ja klar, weil ich bin immer grösser, dann stehen die da, diese Menschen und dann sind die da und ich stehe dann da und habe dann so ein Spezial so einen Zoom mit meiner Brille und kann dann gucken. Und es hat mich bei ihr aber nicht interessiert, weil von was sollen sie Mails bekommen? Balder. Balder schickt ein lustiges GIF. Aber glaubst du, die müssen wirklich nach Berlin oder sammeln einfach nur für das Stand-Up-Programm? Okay, Sicherheitseinweisungen und alle holen die Blöcke raus und alles, okay, jetzt, jetzt. Bring me the Gags. Komm, komm, komm, wo ist es, wo ist es? Ich glaube, wir werden viele Fluggags nochmal von den beiden hören. Ist euch aufgefallen, dass man irgendwann einfach nicht mehr geklatscht hat im Flügel? Es war immer ein Problem, es hat mich immer genervt, dass man klatscht am Ende eines Fluges. Tut man nicht mehr. Von jetzt auf gleich. Es war so 2008, 2009, hat man angefangen, nicht mehr zu klatschen. Ist euch das aufgefallen? Niemandem ist aufgefallen. Ich weiss es nicht, irgendwann hören solche Dinge einfach auf. Ja.
Ich glaube, irgendwann, wenn einfach einer den Mut hat und einfach nichts zu machen.
Gibt es noch Emus?
Emos? Emos? Nee, ich glaube, irgendjemand hat irgendjemandem gesagt, das ist doch scheiße und alle so, ja stimmt. Quatsch. Auch beendet. Und viel Arbeit, sich die ganze Zeit zu schminken und so weiter. Ich glaube, man kann solche Trends auch beenden. Fidget Spinner? Heute? Ich meine, irgendwo in Botswana ist wirklich einfach ein 60 Meter hoher Berg Fidget Spinner. Und einfach so Kinder leben darin und haben auch keinen Bock mehr drauf und ich finde es auch nicht cool. Aber irgendjemand lebt in diesem Berg Fidget Spinner und hat da so eine Tür drin und dann so, kommen Sie rein. Man müsste nachhaltigere Trends. Der Tisch ist aus Fidget Spinnern und alles, alles dreht sich den ganzen Tag. Und alle essen von einem Tisch aus Fidget Spinner mit diesen kleinen Tellern von Herrn der Ringe. Man denkt sich, das ist kein Haus, wo Kinder aufwachsen sollten. Ich wollte als Kind immer in der Müllhalde leben. Ich fand, das war eine romantische Vorstellung, der Müllhalde zu leben, wo man alles finden kann. Und dann irgendwie so, dann baue ich mal ein Flugzeug aus alten Margarinendosen und so. Und dann fliege ich weg und dann habe ich meine eigene Welt in der Müllhr. Ja. Ich finde das total spannend. Ich überlege, ob ich so irrationelle Träume hatte, glaube ich. Es gibt auch irgendwo in der Nähe von meiner Heimatschaft so einen Berg, so einen Hügel, wo einfach eine Müllhalde übergrast wurde. So, die haben da einfach so Gras hingeworfen und es ist drüber gewachsen. Und es ist einfach ein Hügel, es sieht ganz normal aus und du weisst einfach, darunter könnte eine Playstation 2 sein. Kein! Vielleicht wurden wir tief genug Gräbs, findest du eine externe Vesper. In Cham gibt es den Galgenberg und man weiss, was darunter liegt. Wirklich? Leichen? Ja, wahrscheinlich. Oder Galgen? Galgen. Wir haben ja diese 2000 Galgen, wohin damit? Aber ich glaube, dann wurde mir gesagt, dass jede Stadt irgendwo einen Galgenberg hat, weil irgendwo gab es halt immer einen Berg. Ja, einen Friedhof hat einfach auch nicht. Ciao. Da hat jemand seinen Galgen vergessen, der merkt, oh scheiße, jetzt hab ich... Er steht wohl nicht so auf Galgenhumor. Oh, das war die Show. Sehr schön. Das war die Show. Nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, wenn man gräbt, findet man immer was. Ich glaube auch, dass man immer irgendwas findet. Ich glaube, so ein Archäologe, der läuft so durch die Welt und denkt sich da und gräbt einfach und findet dann irgendwie so Düpfel und so ein Kram. Stimmt, und Paläontologen sind eigentlich nur sehr optimistische Archäologen, die sagen, wir finden was und ich weiß sogar, was wir finden. Dinosaurier. Oder Paläontologen sind dann wie so Assfresser, die so, oh wir suchen Troja, oh wir haben hier einen Zahn gefunden, dann kommt der Paläontologe und sagt, okay, cool, den nehme ich mit und fliegt wieder zurück. In dieses Paläontologenhemd, ganz viele Zähne schon drin. Glaubst du, das wird nochmal Mode, so dieses Paläontologenhemd, mit so dieser grossen, wo der gesamte Frontbereich eine Tasche ist? Nicht hier so eine normale Kängurutasche oder so eine Brusttasche, sondern alles ist Tasche. Du hast mehr oder weniger ein T-Shirt und dann nochmal ein zweites Taschenshirt oben, das nur unten so zusammengenäht ist. Und dann kannst du überall, in deinen ganzen Körper rein, nochmal überall, überall alles volle Sachen tun, sodass du dann fast wie so einen zweiten Papa hast. Du beschreibst so eine Anglerweste, wie so sehr viele Taschen. Nee, ich rede nicht davon von vielen Taschen, ich rede von einer riesigen Tasche. Beschreib noch mal ganz genau, wie du das hast. Eine Tasche, die alles umringt, das du wirklich überall links und rechts und dann schüttelst du dich so. Ich habe jetzt eine neue Jacke, die ich einfach schön fand. Nachteil ist, die hat halt nur einen Reisverschluss, der bis hier oben geht. Und Leute, es ist so fucking anstrengend, immer auszuziehen und anzuziehen. Ich habe es wirklich noch nie geschafft, irgendwie einen Pullover auszuziehen, ohne mich komplett auszuziehen. Ich nehme immer so, das ist ganz schön warm, ich ziehe einen Pullover aus, nackt einfach. Oh, okay, sorry, sorry. Da war ich abends mit Leuten verabredet irgendwie und dann hatte ich diese Jacke an und dann stand ich erst mal zehn Minuten. Und dann stand da souert. Das ist aber lächerlich. Und es zieht sich einfach alles aus, Herzschrittmacher draußen, alles so, oh fuck. Warum bist du verkabelt? Ich bin schlechter Mafiosin. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie Leute das machen, die einfach nur diesen, ich glaube, es geht gar nicht. Nee. Ich will mal jemanden coolen sehen, so richtig coolen, weil diese Jacke haben oft coole an, so richtig coole Leute. Coole Leute haben Pullover an, das ist seine Beobachtung. Diese Jacken, wo der weiss nicht, dass du bis hier geht. Ich verstehe nicht, wie die das machen. Machen die dann... Ja, aber die haben dann meist eine sehr gute Figur, die sie kurz zeigen wollen oder so. Wahrscheinlich, vielleicht ist das sogar der Trick. Ich denke nur, wenn du so wahnsinnig viel Zeit für ein Sixpack investierst, dann bist du ja auch so ein bisschen so ein Sixpack-Tolkin, der immer ins Gespräch mit einfließen lassen will, so klopf, klopf, klopf, herein, ich weiß nicht, was Sixpack-Gags sind oder so. Heute habe ich zwei Sixpacks mitgebracht. Hey, jetzt hat gerade jemand gehustet, ich sag's nochmal, ich habe heute zwei Sixpacks mitgebracht, okay, 200 Stunden für das Video. Ja, ich glaube, Leute, die es haben, lassen es sich wissen. Ich glaube, die ziehen extra zu enge Pullover an, damit sie die dann so rüberstülpen können. Huch, jetzt bin ich oben ohne jetzt. Das ist ja, lass ich so, für den Rest der Party einfach. Hatte jemand ein Sixpack? Hat irgendwer vom Podcast-Urkublikum ein Sixpack? Das hört mich, oder hat einer von den Schräflingen da hinten. Nee, ganz im Ernst, ohne Scheiss, ihr wollt doch, dass Leute das wissen. Ne, niemand. Ich mein gut, er hat kein T-Shirt an, von daher. Wahnsinn, ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen. Aber haben wir so eine enge Zielgruppe? Naja, ich weiss nicht, aber als ich bei dem besagten Hotel eingecheckt bin, war Hotel so, ja hier ihr Zimmer wunderbar und dann und man muss ja manchmal im Alltag spielen, einfach mitspielen. Und dann sagt er so, es tut mir wirklich leid, aber das Fitnessstudio ist leider zu. Und ich so, oh nein, oh scheiße, oh fuck, oh scheiße, das ist jetzt genau heute, heute. Angefangen zu weinen. Und wirklich Tränen laufen mir über die Wangen. Und er so, ach tut mir so leid, das tut mir so nicht. Und ich so, oh nein, oh scheiße. Ich bin so aus meinem Zimmer geschnurft, nein, schrecklich. Man spielt manchmal mit, ne, bei anderen Leuten. Ich besuche eine neue Wohnung in Köln. Ich will die Pathologie nehmen an. Das ist zu wild. Das Kratzen in der Nacht. Dieser Gestank. Und tatsächlich suche ich einfach eine schöne Wohnung irgendwo in Köln. Und da habe ich jetzt schon ein paar Wohnungsbesichtigungen hinter mir. Und mich interessieren drei Dinge. Preis, Lage. Und passt mein riesiges Bild ins Wohnzimmer. Passt mein riesiges Bild ins Wohnzimmer. Und wie ist die Zimmeraufteilung. Ja, so. Diese drei Dinge, Preis, Lage und passt mein riesiges Bild ins Wohnzimmer und wie ist die Zimmeraufteilung. Diese drei Dinge, die weist man nach einer Bewohnungsbesichtigung relativ schnell. Jetzt hat aber dieser ein Typ gesagt, ich habe mir eine halbe Stunde für Sie genommen. Und ich dachte mir vorher schon so, fuck, was will ich denn eine halbe Stunde mit dem besprechen? Ich muss 29 Minuten füllen, zum Alltag. Es ist weider Impro, sehr sehr spezifische Impro wird das dann. Und dann, wie ich da war, nach zwei Minuten waren alle Fragen gestellt und dann, irgendwo bin ich dann so rumgelaufen durch die Wohnung und dann habe ich so an die Wände geklopft. Und die waren, sie, die stabil. Was ist das hier für ein Holz? Eichenholz. Bei Eichenholz sagt man ja, dass es sehr laut ist. Ja, ja. Fenster sind doppelt isoliert? Ne, einfach. Keine Ahnung. Ist das besser? Ist das wie einlagig? Also, wie einlagiges Klopapier? Weiss ich nicht. Da habe ich die ganze Zeit Fragen gestellt, die ich mir ausgedacht habe. Und irgendwann war ich im Keller mit ihm. Keine Ahnung, wie das passiert ist, aber irgendwann ist mir die Frage eingefallen, gibt es auch ein Kellerabteil und er so, ja, gibt's, wollen Sie das jetzt sehen?
Oh nein, gibt's auch einen Skilift? Ja, ich gehe draußen einfach, da fährst du hoch und dann musst du wieder runter.
Und dann gab's, es war wie so eine Sitcom-Folge irgendwie und dann gab's den Cut nach der Wer Werbung und ich stand mit ihm im Keller. Und dann standen wir vor den Waschmaschinen und dann ist mir aufgefallen, weil ich wollte ja Gespräch machen und ich hatte noch 25 Minuten auf der Uhr, ist mir aufgefallen, dass da kein Platz mehr ist für eine weitere Waschmaschine. Dann habe ich ihm gesagt, ja, aber hier ist ja gar kein Platz mehr für eine weitere Waschmaschine. Und dann habe ich wirklich die ganzen 20 Minuten rumbekommen, um einen Platz zu suchen dafür. undieben rum. Ich wusste auch zu den Zeiten schon, dass diese Wohnung nicht für mich ist, weil die so teuer war für alle genannten Sachen. Aber du sagst, ich lasse den Makler einfach nochmal 20 Minuten Waschmaschinen schieben. Ja, und wir haben, man braucht nämlich, ich weiß nicht, ob du das weißt, jetzt weiß ich das, für einen Trockner brauchst du so ein Abluftungsding. Und wir haben die ganzen Rohre rausgenommen und geguckt und und dann gerückelt, ob da noch Platz ist für so ein weiteres Ding und so und dann hat er mir, muss er den Schlüssel besorgen von meinem Kellerabteil, was wir dann aufgemacht haben, wo wir dann reingegangen sind, Licht gesucht haben, noch eine Glühbirne gewechselt haben aus einem anderen Kellerabteil, damit er mir zeigen kann, ja hier ist wirklich Platz für eine weitere Waschmaschine, da könnte man die hinstellen, dann habe ich oben an dem Holz ihn checken lassen, ob man da dieses Rohr durchlegen könnte, einfach weil ich dachte, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach gehen, wir bohren jetzt einfach mal ein Loch und gucken einfach mal wie weit wir kommen, ja.
Aber dann habe ich mit ihm so ein ganz weirdes Gespräch darüber geführt, wie seltsam ist, und das hat er mir sehr recht gegeben, wie seltsam es eigentlich ist, dass so ein Haushalt dann sehr viele Waschmaschinen hat, jeder einzelne Haushalt hat einfach eine Waschmaschine, man könnte einfach eine theoretisch hinstellen und so eine Excel-Tabelle dranlegen und gucken, dass man sich einfach aufteilt. Aber alle, da gab es dann schon eine Bosch, eine AEG, eine gute Miele, dann nochmal das Ganze in Trocknern und man denkt so, warum mal ein bisschen... Ja gut, aber ich meine, geht es denn bei solchen Produkten wirklich um die Funktion oder nicht auch um ein gewisses Statussymbol? Stefan. Ja, es ging im Kern darum. Du willst doch zeigen, ey, ich kann mir eine schöne Medion-Waschmaschine leisten. Ich habe die 400 Euro auf der Kante, ist das kein Problem. Und so habe ich auch mit dem gesprochen und dann dachte mir, komm, wir kriegen das noch hin. Und dann irgendwann war die Zeit vorbei und ich bin sofort raus und habe gesagt, nee, ist nicht so wichtig, tschau. Aber es stimmt, ich habe auch oft so, wo mich jemand fragt, haben Sie noch Fragen? Und ich mir denke, ich sollte jetzt eigentlich noch Fragen haben. Irgendwie so ein Mietwagen, irgendwie keine Ahnung. Ah, okay, hier ist der Schlüssel, haben Sie noch Fragen? Und ich so, und das hat schon vier Räder, oder? Also sind wir auf derselben Seite, ja, genau, vier, okay, okay. Und es gibt auf dem Rücksitz kein Lenkrad nochmal extra. Nee ne, genau, nur das Lenkrad vorn, ah, okay, alles klar, dann nehme ich es, okay, einfach, du kannst dich einfach sagen, ne, mir ist alles egal, ich nehme alles. Das kannst du nicht bringen, du musst mitspielen, das Leben, das ist alles Schauspielerei, ach, das ist alles, ja, irgendwie, man ist doch, wer ist man, wer ist man eigentlich, wer ist man eigentlich, wer bin ich, wer bin ich, man lebt viel mehr für andere Leute als für sich selbst, warum nicht einfach mal sagen, ich lebe für mich selbst und nicht für die anderen. Ja, und alle sagen im Mauerhaus von Schmiede ist es so, aber man verstellt sich nur Selbstdarstellung. Das Leben ist Selbstdarstellung, Leute. Ja, das stimmt. Ich habe euch versprochen, dass ihr heute was lernt. Ihr geht heute raus und wisst, die Hauptstadt von Botswana heisst Bots. Das wisst ihr, das müsst ihr wissen. Ja, das müsst ihr wissen. Hat keiner ein Sixpack von euch? Echt enttäuscht. Es gibt auch Eightpack, es gibt da noch mal einen oben drauf. Wo man einfach noch mal zwei, die einfach sagen, so die zwei Muskeln, die sonst nie gebraucht werden. Wir, wir, okay, okay, fuck jetzt los. Okay, komm raus. Scheiße, scheiße, scheiße, was machen wir, wir ziehen hier, oder was? Wir sind draußen, wir haben es geschafft. Was ist denn motivationstechnisch nach dem Sixpack dann passiert? Dass er dachte, ein bisschen mehr geht noch. Reicht, reicht. Naja, aber für einen Eightpack, da hast du ja vorher einen Sixpack. Ja, vor allem, es gibt ja so Superheldenfiguren und die müssen sich ja immer übertrumpfen gegeneinander. Und die haben dann teilweise noch viel mehr Knubbel und die haben dann einfach so den ganzen, es klingt, sieht aus wie so ein Leprakranker, der einfach überall so Knubbel hat und man denkt sich so, was soll das überhaupt sein? Einfach noch so, wir haben zwei Muskeln mehr als Superman oder einen mehr, damit man sich so ein bisschen hochsteigert. Das ist wirklich weird. Das stimmt. Ich habe ein Referat gehört über Superman, um den Kreis zu schliessen. Ja, das stimmt schon, das stimmt schon und tatsächlich, es war sehr, sehr, und das ist wirklich absurd. Und manchmal denkt man sich ja, ist das wirklich passiert, oder ist es alles Fiktion? Versuche ich nur, meine Vergangenheit interessanter zu machen? Weil da hatte ich Referat, und ich war sehr, sehr aufgeregt immer vor Referaten, und da hatte ich halt Referat über Superman, und dann war davor noch Chemie, und ich hatte davor irgendwie alle Unterlagen, lese mir alles nochmal durch und hier und da. Und dann irgendwann tatsächlich fragte eine Mitschülerin in Chemie, mitten aus dem Nichts, da ging es dann um so verschiedene Elemente, irgendwie dann so Strontium, Germanium, so ganz weirde. Und dann sagte die tatsächlich, ähm, warte, jetzt fällt mir das Wort nicht ein. Krümmel, ja genau, krümmel, genau, sehr gut. Du warst, ah Bernd, sehr gut. Und dann fragt die tatsächlich, ja und ich kenne noch Kryptonit und alle lachen, aber sie nicht, für sie war das kein Gag, sie dachte, wie ist das mehr ein Element und alle lachen und ich dachte mir so, ich halte gleich ein Referat über Superman, verdammt nochmal, ist das meine Superhelden-Origin-Story jetzt gerade, dass alles hier zusammenkommt, was geht los? Nein, war es nicht. Aber ich dachte mir, was für ein fucking Zufall. Ich habe nachts mal, ich wache nämlich auch immer auf und ich bin aufgewacht, weil ich hinter mir eine Kaktus habe. Und ich wollte und dann habe ich irgendwann im Schlaf so mich umgedreht, habe in den Kaktus gefasst und dachte mir, ich dachte, ist das der Anfang der langweiligsten Superhelilgeschichte aller Zeiten? Ich werde immer weniger beweglich und mehr zu so einem grünen, stacheligen... Nach 20 Minuten bin ich ausgetrocknet. Warum sind Kakteen immer so gebaut? Was bezweckt denn die Natur mit? Ich weiß nicht, manche sind dann so nach unten irgendwie, das ist wie so ein Daumenkino... Manche gehen auch Wild. Was machen die? Ich glaube, die haben ja auch einfach immer wahnsinnig viel Platz, so in der Wüste, die machen dann so und dann geht's noch mehr. Die gucken mal, wie weit es geht und irgendwann stossen sie so in andere Charaktere und sagen, oh, sorry, sorry, und die sind einfach frech, die gucken einfach, wie weit kann die. Ja, das sind Frechdachse. Das sind Frechdachse. Wann hast du zum letzten Mal unironisch das Wort Frechdachs benutzt? Vor 20 Minuten glaube ich. Ich benutze häufig das Wort Frechdachs. Das ist ja auch ein Rassismus, den Dachsen zu unterstellen, dass sie einfach rautfrech sind. Dass du, wenn du so einen Dachs siehst, du bist so ein Frechdachs. Ich finde es schlecht. Ich finde, wir sollten als Gesellschaft ein Stück weiter sein. Einfach sagen, frech. Oder oder mal die Tiere durchrotieren, frech ganz oder sowas. Muss auch gehen. Das stimmt, frech Ente. Frente. Worte kürzen, Worte zusammenziehen, wenn ihr rausgeht, Worte kürzer machen. Die Frente, sehr gut, finde ich nicht so schlecht. Berlin, Berlin. Berlin, du hast ein bisschen recherchiert. Das erste Mal, als ich in Berlin war, war damals mit meinem Sowi-Grundkurs. Und davor hatten wir so ein Doku geschaut über Berlin, wo die ganze Zeit jemand, und es ist halt weird, wie Sprecher damals bei Dokumentarfilmen immer gesprochen haben. Und er hat die ganze Zeit so gesprochen, Berlin, Berlin, Riesenstand Berlin. Das war diese Stimme, die er drauf hatte. Und man denkt, klar, die Tonaufnahme war nicht so gut damals, aber der hat doch nicht normal gesprochen.
Also wenn die Tonaufnahme schlecht ist, er hat ja nicht, wenn man dann mal guckt, wie er wirklich gesprochen hat, er hat ja nicht gesagt Berlin, Berlin, Riesenstadt Berlin, sondern er hat ja wirklich Berlin, Berlin, da schwingt er so viel Aggression mit und so.
Warum haben Leute so gesprochen? Wie sah die Sprechausbildung damals aus? Ne, sprich mal aggressiver.
Berlin, Berlin, noch ein bisschen enger und viel. Berlin, Berlin! Ja, und jetzt die Tagesschau. Berlin! Ich glaube, man hat einfach gesagt, es muss einfach was Besonderes sein. Ich glaube, heute ist ja so, alles muss authentisch sein und irgendwie alles super natürlich und so und Wackelkamera und möglichst drin sein. Ich glaube, früher war es eher so, nee, wir reissen nicht mal zusammen, das muss ja was Besonderes sein. Du kannst im Fernsehen nicht einfach normal reden, wie du auf der Strasse redest, das ist Fernsehen, so, und dann musst du irgendwie was darstellen, und dann, glaube ich, hast du so diese Künstlichkeit mit drin, und heute ist es dann irgendwie nur noch so, man redet genauso in einem Podcast, wie man normal auch redet. Schönen guten Abend, meine Damen und Herren, sagt man heute, und damals, schönen Abend! Stimmt, aber war Berlin so, wie du es dir vorgestellt hast, aus dieser Doku, oder war es so ein Tor? Ja, war es so ein Tor? Tolle, wilde Stadt, ganz tolle Stadt. Ich kenne nicht so viel von Berlin, ich kenne nur die Touri-Orte und das Huxleys jetzt. Ja, ich fühle mich ja auch, ich habe ja glaube ich drei Jahre in Berlin gewohnt, ich fühle mich aber wie ein Tourist, weil ich habe direkt am Checkpoint Charlie gewohnt und habe eigentlich ein komplettes Touristenleben geführt, obwohl ich hier gewohnt habe. Ich stehe auf und esse erst mal einen Kräpp für 5,60 Euro und das war mein Frühstück und irgendwie irgendwie nachmittags war ich immer beim Checkpoint-Charlie. Da ist mir so eine Kamera auch um, weil das ist, wenn ich hier schon wohne. Und dann gehst du nachmittags zu Starbucks und abends guckst du dir die Berliner Mauer an. Und dann bist du umgezogen zum Alexanderplatz und denkst auch Leute. Und ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, nichts von Berlin gesehen zu haben, außer dieses Curry-Mobil von diesem Currywurst-Museum, das ich auch jeden Tag gesehen habe. Weil das jeden Tag seine Curry-Runde gefahren ist. Es gibt ja das Currywurst-Museum in Berlin und die haben so das Curry-Mobil. Aber was ist spannend an der Geschichte von Currywurst, außer dass man irgendwann gesagt hat, jetzt Curry auf Ketchup? Ja, ich habe mal gehört, dass es da so eine Legende gibt, dass irgendjemand eine Treppe runtergefallen ist und dann ist irgendwie die Wurst in Curry gefallen. Der arme Schauspieler, der in dem Museum über Treppe fallen muss. Der die Wurst spielen muss. Er hat immer so, wir sind so arm, weil Gott Krieg ist, keine Ahnung, ich muss die Wurst jetzt trotzdem essen. Oh, ist sie lecker. So, und die nächsten, und dann kommen die nächsten Touristen. Und das habe ich jeden Tag gesehen, jeden einzelnen Tag. Currywurst ist auch so ein Gericht, sowas kann man noch mal erfinden. Meinst du, noch mal von vorne anfangen? Was Donald Trump für Präsidentschaften ist, ist Currywurst für Gerichte. So, jetzt kann es jeder, jetzt kann jeder mal. Weisst du, was ich erfunden habe als Kind? Ich dachte mir, ich habe als Kind sehr gerne Hotdogs gegessen. Haha, ja, ja, sieht man, sieht man. Und so, ich dachte mir immer so, der Hotdog, ich dachte mir so, wie kann man den Hotdog noch besser machen. Der Hotdog ist schon gut, Wurst in Brot, gut, aber dieser... Diese Gurke nervt, diese ganzen gesunden Sachen da drauf nervt. Nee, dieser elende Brotteil, der hat mich nie überzeugt, aber ich habe gesagt, der braucht wirklich dieses Brot. und letzten Endes habe ich den Spiess umgedreht. Normalerweise schneidest du das Brot auf und legst die Wurst rein. Oh, Wurst auf, schneiden, Brot rein, nein! Ich habe das Brot weggelassen und habe die Wurst aufgeschnitten, längs, aufgeklappt, da Ketchup, Mayonnaise rein, Ketchup und Mayonnaise rein getan und dann das so als Hotdog gegessen. Und das Brot war raus und das war nie wieder gesehen. Ich habe nie wieder Brot gegessen. Probiert das mal, den Hotdog zu... Das ist einfach ein Hotdog-Dog. Einfach zu sagen, ich schneide den Hotdog direkt auf und tu da das geile Zeug rein. Ein Code-Dog vielleicht. Eine Wurst. Man muss aber nicht... Ja, eine Wurst, bis dann von keinerlei was sagen, was das ist. Oder ich glaube, die Brezel soll auch irgendwo in so einen radioaktiven Müll reingefallen sein. Und dann haben die Leute auch gesagt, oh, das ist ja lecker. Das verstehe ich auch nicht genau. Was ist das Laugenbrezel? Man hat doch keine Ahnung von gar nichts. Ja, du brauchst auch für jedes Zeug, ich glaube, wenn du so ein Museum baust, dann musst du dir auch was ausdenken. In Köln gibt es das Senfmuseum. Ja, dann sagst du auch, du hattest Senf und dann hattest du noch die Farbe Gelb und dann sind die irgendwie ineinander gefallen bei einem Ski. Ich weiss nicht, woraus Senf besteht, keine Ahnung wirklich. Das ist eine Senfpflanze? Ja, und da sind dann so Deweleigläser drin oder was? Es gibt eine Senfpflanze, obviously, wo so kleine Körner, die kennt man ja, da nickt jemand heftig. Ein großer Senffang. Ja, zu heftig, Herr Deweleig. So ein Sen ein Senf-Shirt an. Und das Schokoladenmuseum, das ist direkt gegenüber.
Dann sind wir mit der Schule damals nach Köln gefahren, um ins Schokoladenmuseum zu gehen, und gegenüber ist das Senfmuseum.
Es tut mir immer so ein bisschen leid, weil man immer denkt, niemand hat eine Chance gegen das Schokoladenmuseum.
Wenn du im Schokoladenmuseum, dann kannst du in dieser Stadt keine weiteren Museen machen. Vielleicht das Dildo-Museum von mir aus, aber irgendwie noch eine andere Richtung. Aber du kannst nicht weiter in Nahrungsmuseum. Und die werben ja mit diesem grossen Schokobrunnen, wo man so einen Cracker bekommt, den reintauchen kann und dann essen kann. Und dann gegenüber, als sie das irgendwie erfunden haben und dahingestellt haben und die Attraktion groß gemacht haben und plakatiert haben. Was hat das Senfmuseum da gedacht? Scheiße, was machen wir? Leute, was machen wir? Wir brauchen Ideen, Leute! Vielleicht eine Wurst aufschneiden, das ist einfach Senf rein. Keine Ahnung. Ich weiss nicht, ob du dich noch daran erinnerst, aber wir hatten mal einen Sketch-YouTube-Kanal, Gute Arbeit Originals hieß der, und dann wurden immer, ja, danke schön, und dann haben wir jetzt ein Sketch geschrieben mit der Erdnuss, mit der Spur von Nüssen,
mit dem Investigative, wie ist das mit dem Spur von Nüssen, und dann schreibt man halt so den Text. Du hast mein Regiedebüt. Genau, da hast du Regiedebüt. Zum ersten Mal. Da gibt es ja immer so verschiedene, kann man auch mal sagen, fantastisch mal. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, doch fantastisch richtig geführt, seitdem nie wieder.
Völlig zu Recht, das ist sehr teuer, zwei Millionen Euro. Und ihr fragt euch, warum es gute Arbeit nicht mehr gibt. Und es lief dann immer so, wir haben ja die Sketche aufgeschrieben, Staffel auch, und dann gibt man das ja so ab an andere Leute, die dann organisieren. Und dann irgendwann kriegt man nur noch den Drehtag, und dann kriegt man den Drehtag, Informationen, dann steht dann so drauf, ah ok, wann geht's los, aha ok, Drehort Schokoladenmuseum. Was? Und ich dachte mir, bitte was? Wird das Erdnussmuseum nicht viel besser passen? Wir drehen den ganzen Tag im fucking Schokoladenmuseum und ich dachte mir halt wirklich, dass halt so, ok, drehen, ha ha ha, la la la, Schnitt, Drehpause und ich lege mich unter diesen Schokoladenbrunnen, einfach bis zumindest der nächste Take losgeht. Aber tatsächlich, wir haben dann die Nacht durchgedreht, weil die Szene spielte Nacht, das heißt, nach Öffnungszeiten wurde alles abgeschaltet und dann kamen wir und dann drehen die den Schokobrunnen ab. Das heißt, du sitzt wirklich Drehpause, auf Drehs muss man oft sehr lange warten und dann sitzt du da vor so einem abgeschalteten Schokobrunnen und denkst dir einfach, alle meine Träume sind mit der Schokolade verschwunden. Ja, und man denkt auch so, das ist das magische Land, wo Schoko fliesst und so, die können einfach abstellen. Ich dachte, der Schokobrunnen wäre so was natürliches, was so natürlich aus dem Land der Elfen heraus fliesst und dann hast du halt immer diese Schokofontäne und darum haben die dieses Museum gebaut. Nein, da ist eine Steckdose, die können die rausziehen. Wo geht die Schokolade hin, wenn die dann da unten, gehen die dann wieder hoch oder ist das mal dasselbe? Judith weiss es nicht. Judith, tatsächlich nach der Show beantwortet Judith alle eure Fragen, kommt gerne in die Lobby und ihr könnt sie alles fragen. Macht danach ein Q&A einfach draußen. Sie weiss alles, sie weiss alles. Aber das hat Spaß gemacht, so alleine in einem Museum, ich meine, könnte man einen Film draus machen? Könnte man einen Museum machen. Das macht schon Spaß, immer so alleine an Orten zu sein, wo sonst alles ist, das hat man oft bei Drehs. Ja, das stimmt. Wir hatten zum Beispiel auch den Nazi-Sketch mit der Nazi-PR-Filme und das war in so einem komplett leeren Flughafen, so einem alten Flughafen, der komplett leer war und du bist dann alleine und überall dann diese Sachen und dann so bist du immer alleine. Und das macht schon Spaß, so irgendwie dann in so einem Krankenhaus auch alles leer. Es gibt ja teilweise Orte, die einfach leer sind. Es gibt ja irgendwie ein Krankenhaus, wo einfach ein Stockwerk leer ist, wo dann ständig Leute drehen, weil die Platz haben. Das weiss man als normaler Mensch gar nicht, wenn man nicht dreht ab und zu. Das wisst ihr als normaler Menschen gar nicht, was Florian alles so weiss.
Das wisst ihr dummen, niederen, erbärmlichen Menschen, ihr wisst so gut wie nichts gar nichts, vor allem die Seite hier, die weiss fast nichts, fast nichts, fast nichts.
Siehste, genau so fängt das an.
Ja, ja genau, das stimmt.
Ich möchte ganz kurz eine Sache sagen, bevor wir gleich gehen. Ich habe die Tage gehört, es ist furchtbar. Weißt du, wie die Serie Alf endet? Weißt du nicht mehr, wie die Serie Alf endet? Die Serie Alf. Da möchte ich ganz kurz drüber sprechen. Sympathischen, Katzen essenden Monster. So. Ich glaube, es gibt eine Serie, wo am Ende rauskommt, dass alles geträumt war. Ich glaube, das ist Roseanne. Spoiler. Ich glaube, es ist nicht Alf. Dann gibt es, ich weiß nicht, er fliegt zurück auf seinen Melmack. Nee, Melmack ist ja zerstört worden. Alf ist ja auf Melmack geboren. Und dann gab es da ein Problem, weil die hatten Energieprobleme und dann ist Melmack auf die Erde gekommen. Man muss sagen, es gibt, ich weiß nicht wie viele Staffeln, es gibt, sagen wir, erfinden wir eine Zahl, 95 Staffeln. Judith korrigiert dann in den Kommentaren. Ich glaube, es waren schon elf oder so, keine Ahnung, wo es immer darum ging, dass die Familie ihn beschützt und ihn bei sich versteckt. In der letzten Folge vor den Behörden, die er jetzt untersuchen wollen und den Atiz töten wollen, für Experimente. Das ist eine lustige Sitcom, Leute lachen darüber, Kinder gucken, das ist was für die ganze Familie, toll, hahaha. Die Autoren haben sich bei der letzten Staffel, die letzte Folge explizit, die weirdest Story ausgedacht, die ich jemals gehört habe, weil das ist eine absurde Idee. Du musst einfach diese Serie nach Hause fahren, du kennst die Charaktere, du hast alle Charaktere liebgewonnen, es ist einfach diese Serie nach Hause zu fahren. Die haben sich gedacht, okay, Ronda, mit der er Kontakt aufgenommen hat, diese andere Alien-Braut, die schafft er es, Kontakt aufzunehmen. Und die kommt mit einem Raumschiff, um ihn abzuholen. Und Familie Tanner bringt ihn dann zu diesem Ort, wo sie sich verabredet haben. Sie kommt, Ronda kommt, und in dem Moment tauchen die Behörden auf, sehen das und man
denkt so, ja jetzt Alf, hau ab vor denen und dann zieht Rhonda ab, weil sie Angst bekommt, weil die
Behörden kommen, die Behörden schnappen ihn und die Serie ist vorbei. Das ist das Ende von fucking Alf.
Die Behörden haben Alf? Die Behörden haben Alf und das war ein Abspann.
Und die quälen jetzt Alf und machen Experimente. Das war Alf, ja, tschau, das war's von uns, tschüss.
Wie wenig Bock hatten die Autoren an dem Punkt eigentlich sehr mehr.
Finkt euch Fans.
Aber eigentlich ganz gut, zu sagen, du hast deine Kinder, sind am Ende einfach so, nee, das Leben ist nicht gut.
Nee, das Leben und Aliens sterben, tschau, das war's von uns.
Ja, und jetzt bist du erwachsen.
So.
Und einfach mit dem Ende von Alf ist deine Kindheit zu Ende, das ist auch wichtig, so eine Kindheit zu beenden und zu sagen, jetzt geht's los. Das ist richtig gut. Das fand ich echt lustig. Das heißt, Alf sitzt bis heute in Gefangenschaft. Genau. Free Alf. Die Botschaft ist so ein bisschen so, genau, ihr könnt mit Sitcoms gerne vor euren Problemen fliehen, aber dann ist das Sitcom vorbei und dann sind die Probleme wieder da. Erinnere mich ein bisschen an das Podcast zu, vorher.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt.
Denn jetzt gehen eure Probleme wieder los.
Viel Spaß in der echten Welt, viel Spaß in Berlin.
Aber vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart, vielen Dank, dass ihr rumgekommen seid.
Vielen Dank, wir sehen uns gleich noch am Merchshop, falls ihr vorbeikommen wollt und kommt reichlich.
Kommt reichlich, kommt in Scharen und kauft vor allem.
Vielen Dank Berlin, ihr wart fantastisch.
Hat richtig viel Spaß gemacht, viel, viel Dank für euch jetzt die Woche.
Ciao, vielen Dank.